Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The afternoon of Wednesday, September 5, 2012 was a pleasant one in Chervaline, a small wooded community located in the French Alps region of Oort Savoy. Sharing nearby borders with Switzerland and Italy, the area is known for its mountain landscapes and the medieval towns that dot Lake Anasi,
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上本集节目的节目说明。2012年9月5日星期三的下午，在法国阿尔卑斯山奥尔特萨瓦地区的谢尔瓦林（Chervaline），一个林木茂密的小社区，天气十分宜人。该地区与瑞士和意大利接壤，以其山地景观和点缀在阿纳西湖（Lake Anasi）畔的中世纪城镇而闻名。
a sparkling body of water considered to be the cleanest lake in Europe. In the warmer months, visitors from all over flock to the region to bask in the tranquil surroundings, swim in the clear waters, and enjoy everything that Lake Anisee has to offer. British retiree Brett Martin had a holiday house not far from Shervalene. He took advantage of the sunny weather and took off on his mountain bike for a leisurely ride through the village of roughly 207 residents. He passed by the sprinkling of old country homes and pastures
阿纳西湖是一片波光粼粼的水域，被认为是欧洲最清澈的湖泊。在温暖的月份，来自各地的游客蜂拥而至，沉浸在宁静的环境中，在清澈的湖水中游泳，享受阿纳西湖所提供的一切。英国退休人员布雷特·马丁（Brett Martin）在离谢尔瓦林不远的地方有一栋度假屋。他利用晴朗的天气，骑上山地自行车，在拥有约207名居民的村庄里悠闲地骑行。他经过了零星分布的古老乡村住宅和牧场，
before the only thing on either side of him was woodland. About 10 minutes outside of Shervaline, Brett turned onto Coom Deer, a steep uneven road that wound uphill through dense, uninhabited forest and past rushing streams. Brett had done the trip before. He knew that there were no other turn-offs until the three-kilometer mark when the public road gave way to a clearing called Le Martinet. This served as a small secluded parking area and was typically used as a starting point for visitors to explore the surrounding walking tracks and hiking trails. It also signalled the end of the public road. From Le Martinère,
随后他两侧就只剩下林地了。在谢尔瓦林外约10分钟路程处，布雷特转入库姆鹿路（Coom Deer），这是一条陡峭且崎岖不平的道路，蜿蜒向上穿过茂密、无人居住的森林，经过湍急的溪流。布雷特以前走过这条路。他知道在三公里处之前没有其他岔路口，在那里，公共道路通向一片名为勒马蒂内（Le Martinet）的空地。这里是一个僻静的小型停车区，通常被游客用作探索周围步行道和徒步小径的起点。这也标志着公共道路的终点。从勒马蒂内出发，
Kum Deer became a restricted route marked with a no-entry sign. Although hikers commonly used the route, the only vehicles with authorization to access it were forestry workers. Brett powered on until Le Martiné clearing was in sight. By this point, it was roughly 3.55 p.m. He looked ahead and noticed something. something in the middle of the road, a lightweight racing bicycle. Brett wondered why its owner would have left it there, but his thoughts were suddenly
库姆鹿路变成了一条标有禁止通行标志的限制路线。虽然徒步旅行者经常使用这条路线，但唯一获准进入的车辆是林业工人。布雷特继续骑行，直到勒马蒂内空地出现在视野中。此时大约是下午3点55分。他向前看去，注意到了一些东西。在路中间有一些东西，一辆轻便的赛车自行车。布雷特想知道为什么它的主人会把它留在那里，但他的思绪突然
interrupted when a young, dark-haired girl stumbled out onto the road. She was covered in blood, her head and shoulder clearly injured. Brett watched her sway from side to side before she collapsed face-first onto the ground. Brett rushed to the girl's aide. Her eyes were rolling around as though she was about to lose consciousness. Brett was a former Royal Air Force pilot, and he used his first aid knowledge to gently move the girl off the road
被打断了，因为一个年轻的黑发女孩跌跌撞撞地走到了路上。她浑身是血，头部和肩膀明显受伤。布雷特看着她左右摇晃，然后脸朝下倒在地上。布雷特冲过去帮助这个女孩。她的眼睛在转动，好像快要失去知觉了。布雷特曾是一名英国皇家空军飞行员，他利用自己的急救知识轻轻地将女孩移出路面，
and place her in the recovery position. That's when he noticed the Maroon BMW Series 5 station wagon stopped to the left of the parking area, facing the road. The same vehicle had passed Brett just a few minutes earlier. He'd remembered it because it had
并将她置于复苏体位。就在那时，他注意到一辆栗色的宝马5系旅行车停在停车区左侧，面向道路。同一辆车几分钟前刚刚超过布雷特。他记得它，因为它有
British license plates and it was right-hand drive. Now its engine was revving as one of its rear wills spun in a mound of gravel. On the ground in front of the BMW, a middle-aged man was lying in a pool of blood. Brett recognized the man as the owner of the discarded bicycle. The two had passed one another towards the start of Kum Deer. Brett had initially tried to keep up with the other cyclist, but had given up and lingered back at his own pace. Thinking that the cyclist and car must have collided,
英国车牌，而且是右舵驾驶。现在它的引擎在轰鸣，其中一个后轮在碎石堆中打转。在宝马车前的地上，一名中年男子躺在血泊中。布雷特认出这名男子就是那辆被丢弃的自行车的主人。两人在库姆鹿路起点附近曾擦肩而过。布雷特最初试图跟上另一位骑行者，但放弃了，并按自己的节奏落在了后面。想到骑行者和汽车一定发生了碰撞，
Brett's immediate thought was that the revving BMW could alert forward at any moment and cause further injury to the cyclist. He rushed to move the man out of the way, only to realise that he hadn't been hit by the car at all. He'd been shot multiple times in the head. Brett realized that the BMW's windows were riddled with bullet holes. He moved closer, only to see that the interior of the vehicle was covered with blood. Inside, a middle-aged male was slumped over in the driver's seat. In the back seat was a
布雷特的第一反应是，轰鸣的宝马车随时可能向前冲，对骑行者造成进一步伤害。他冲过去想把那名男子移开，却意识到他根本没有被车撞到。他的头部被多次枪击。布雷特意识到宝马车的车窗上布满了弹孔。他走近一看，发现车内满是鲜血。车内，一名中年男子瘫倒在驾驶座上。后座上有一位
middle-aged woman with an elderly woman beside her. All three had been shot in the head. Brett smashed the bullet-ridden driver-side window and reached in to turn off the ignition. He took out his mobile phone to call for help, but there was no reception. He faced a dilemma. Did he leave the wounded girl there, or did he attempt to take her with him and risk worsening her injuries? Scared that the shooter was still in the area and could target him next, Brett got back on his bike and rode for help, leaving the injured girl by the side of the road. Within minutes, Brett Martin encountered a car full of French hikers who were able to get a mobile signal and summon emergency services. Paramedics, rescue personnel and teams of police sped to the area.
中年妇女，旁边还有一位老妇人。三人头部均中弹。布雷特砸碎了布满弹孔的驾驶座车窗，伸手关掉了点火开关。他拿出手机呼救，但没有信号。他面临一个两难境地。是把受伤的女孩留在那里，还是尝试带她一起走，冒着加重她伤势的风险？由于害怕枪手还在附近并可能将他作为下一个目标，布雷特骑上自行车去寻求帮助，将受伤的女孩留在了路边。几分钟内，布雷特·马丁遇到了一辆载满法国徒步旅行者的汽车，他们能够获得手机信号并召唤紧急服务。医护人员、救援人员和警察小组迅速赶往该地区。
The wounded girl was airlifted the hospital in a critical condition. As doctors assessed her injuries, they realised that she'd received a gunshot wound to the shoulder before being brutally beaten in the head. Her orbital bone was fractured and her skull was cracked, resulting in a traumatic brain injury. The girl was put into an induced coma while surgeons tried desperately to save her life. But there was nothing to be done for the cyclist or those inside of the, the BAMW. All four were pronounced dead at the scene. A cursory search of the woods surrounding the crime scene was conducted, with the helicopter passing overhead. Nothing was found
受伤的女孩被空运到医院，情况危急。当医生评估她的伤势时，他们意识到她在头部遭到残酷殴打之前，肩膀曾中过枪。她的眼眶骨折，头骨破裂，导致了创伤性脑损伤。女孩被置于诱导昏迷状态，外科医生拼命试图挽救她的生命。但对于那名骑行者或宝马车内的人来说，已经无能为力了。四人均被当场宣布死亡。警方对犯罪现场周围的树林进行了初步搜查，直升机在头顶盘旋。没有发现任何东西
to indicate the shooter was still in the area. Police at the scene decided it was best to wait for the specialist forensic team to arrive from Paris before examining the interior of the vehicle. The car windows were so badly cracked by bullet holes that a single movement could cause one to collapse, thus damaging crucial evidence. The deceased cyclist still had his wallet on him, which led to him being identified as 45-year-old Silvan Moliere. The quiet and reserved father of three lived just 20 kilometres east of Cherville in the small town of Ujine. Sylvain's partner, Claire, had recently given birth to a baby boy. A dedicated father, Silvan had taken extended paternity leave from his job as a production worker
表明枪手还在该地区。现场警察决定最好等待巴黎的专业法医小组到达后再检查车内情况。车窗被弹孔震裂得非常严重，任何轻微的移动都可能导致车窗坍塌，从而损坏关键证据。死去的骑行者身上仍带着钱包，这使他被确认为45岁的西尔万·莫利埃（Silvan Moliere）。这位安静内敛的三个孩子的父亲住在谢尔瓦林以东仅20公里的于济讷（Ujine）小镇。西尔万的伴侣克莱尔（Claire）最近刚生下一个男婴。作为一名尽职的父亲，西尔万从他的生产工人工作中请了延长的陪产假，
to take care of his young son and two teenage children from a previous marriage. Sylvain was a keen cyclist who enjoyed riding the local trails. That afternoon, he'd wanted to try a new route, so he headed up the Coomdeer Road at the recommendation of Claire's father. The British registered BAMW was traced back to Le Solitaire Dulac, a campsite roughly 14 kilometres north of Coomdeer. The occupants of the BAMW were identified as 50-year-old Saad Al-Hilly, an Iraqi-born British citizen who lived in the English village of Claygate. The two women in the back seat were his wife, 47-year-old Iraqi-born Iqbal Al-Hili, and Iqbal's 74-year-old. old mother, Suhela Al-Alaf. The injured girl was the couple's seven-year-old daughter, Zainab.
以照顾他年幼的儿子和与前妻所生的两个十几岁的孩子。西尔万是一位热衷于骑行的骑手，喜欢骑行当地的小径。那天下午，他想尝试一条新路线，于是听从克莱尔父亲的建议，沿着库姆鹿路向上骑行。那辆英国注册的宝马车被追溯到勒索利泰尔杜拉克（Le Solitaire Dulac），这是一个位于库姆鹿路以北约14公里的露营地。宝马车的乘员被确认为50岁的萨阿德·阿尔-希利（Saad Al-Hilly），一名出生于伊拉克的英国公民，住在英国的克莱盖特（Claygate）村。后座的两名女性是他的妻子，47岁的伊克巴尔·阿尔-希利（Iqbal Al-Hili），以及伊克巴尔74岁的母亲苏赫拉·阿尔-阿拉夫（Suhela Al-Alaf）。受伤的女孩是这对夫妇七岁的女儿扎伊纳布（Zainab）。
A caravan registered to Saad Al-Hilly remained exactly where the family had left it, parked alongside their tent. The owner of the campsite told the police that the Al-Hilly family had checked in the previous day of Tuesday, September 4. They'd actually arrived in the area on Saturday, but had stayed at a different campsite for two nights before moving to Les-Sah. Solitaire Dulac. The owner recalled nothing unusual about the family's behavior. Sard had asked about good walking trails in the area, to which the owner had recommended the general area around Chervaline,
一辆萨阿德·阿尔-希利名下的房车停在他们帐篷旁边，位置正是家人离开时的样子。露营地老板告诉警察，阿尔-希利一家是在前一天，即9月4日星期二登记入住的。他们实际上在周六就到达了该地区，但在搬到勒索利泰尔杜拉克之前，在另一个露营地住了两晚。老板回忆说，这家人没有任何异常行为。萨阿德曾询问该地区好的步行路线，老板向他推荐了谢尔瓦林周围的大致区域，
but hadn't signalled out a specific location. Other guests told the police that the El Hilly seemed like an ordinary family on vacation. The guests who were camping next to them recalled the two little girls playing happily. When the questioning officers heard this, they froze. Two little girls. There had only been one young girl found at the crime scene, seven-year-old Zainab. There was only one child seed inside the BMW, so investigators hadn't even thought to check the vehicle for a second child. Cursory searches of the area hadn't revealed any sign of another victim.
但没有指出具体地点。其他客人告诉警察，阿尔-希利一家看起来就像普通的度假家庭。住在他们隔壁露营的客人回忆说，两个小女孩玩得很开心。当审讯的警官听到这个消息时，他们惊呆了。两个小女孩。在犯罪现场只发现了一个小女孩，七岁的扎伊纳布。宝马车内只有一个儿童座椅，所以调查人员甚至没有想到要检查车内是否有第二个孩子。对该地区的初步搜查没有发现任何其他受害者的迹象。
This left two possibilities. Either the second Al-Hilly daughter had run into the woods to escape the shooter and was still out there somewhere, or she'd been abducted. By this point, it was nearing midnight. Authorities had been gathered at the crime scene for close to eight hours. The specialist forensic team had just arrived from Paris, and one officer finally opened to the back door of the BMW. There, cowering silently underneath Iqbal Al-Hiliell. skirt was her four-year-old daughter, Zena. The young girl was terrified, but unharmed.
这留下了两种可能性。要么是阿尔-希利家的第二个女儿跑进树林躲避枪手，现在还在某个地方，要么她被绑架了。此时已近午夜。当局在犯罪现场聚集了近八个小时。巴黎的专业法医小组刚刚到达，一名警官终于打开了宝马车的后门。在那里，蜷缩在伊克巴尔·阿尔-希利的裙子下，是她四岁的女儿泽娜（Zena）。小女孩被吓坏了，但没有受伤。
For eight hours, she'd been frozen in fear, unable to grasp the carnage that had taken place around her. Smiling with relief at finally being found, Zena looked up and said, Where's mummy? I want my mummy. At no point during the attack had Zena exited the car, so she couldn't tell the investigators much.
八个小时来，她一直因恐惧而僵住，无法理解周围发生的屠杀。当终于被发现时，泽娜带着解脱的微笑抬头问道：“妈妈在哪里？我要我的妈妈。”在袭击过程中，泽娜从未离开过车，所以她无法告诉调查人员太多信息。
All she remembered was hearing loud noises before quickly hiding on the floor. Investigators hoped her older sister would be more helpful, but whether Zainab would recover remained to be seen. In the meantime, the priority remained on catching the killer. If the shooting was a random attack conducted by a deranged individual, a quick arrest was needed to stop them from striking again. The deceased inside the BMW were still in possession of their wallets, mobile phones and a digital camera. This ruled out robbery as a motive for the killings.
她只记得听到巨大的响声，然后迅速躲在地板上。调查人员希望她的大姐姐能提供更多帮助，但扎伊纳布能否康复还有待观察。与此同时，首要任务仍然是抓住凶手。如果枪击事件是由一个精神错乱的人进行的随机袭击，那么需要迅速逮捕，以阻止他们再次行凶。宝马车内的死者仍然持有他们的钱包、手机和数码相机。这排除了抢劫作为杀人动机的可能性。
But, strangely, their passports were nowhere to be found either in their car or at their campsite. A forensic search for fingerprints, DNA or any other clues came up empty. All the police had to go by were the spent bullet casings, 21 of which were found at the scene. Using the ballistics and limited physical evidence, investigators deduced that after arriving at Le Matanet, Sard and seven-year-old Zainab likely got out of the car, perhaps to examine a map of the area that was posted to the side of the parking spot. At the same time, Silvan Molyere cycled up.
但奇怪的是，他们的护照在车里或露营地都找不到。法医对指纹、DNA或任何其他线索的搜查一无所获。警察唯一能依靠的就是弹壳，现场发现了21枚。利用弹道学和有限的物证，调查人员推断，在到达勒马蒂内后，萨阿德和七岁的扎伊纳布可能下了车，也许是为了查看停车点旁边张贴的区域地图。与此同时，西尔万·莫利埃骑车过来。
Unbeknownst to all of them, the shooter was hiding nearby, likely in a nearby gully or the surrounding trees. Suddenly, the shots began. It was unclear who was shot first, but one bullet struck Sard in the back, while another knocked Silvan to the ground. Sard then ran back to his BAMW, yelling at Little Zainab to do the same. Slamming and locking the door, he reversed in a semicircle direction, trying desperately to escape the onslaught.
在他们所有人都不知情的情况下，枪手正躲在附近，可能在附近的沟壑或周围的树林里。突然，枪声响起。不清楚谁先中枪，但一颗子弹击中了萨阿德的背部，而另一颗将西尔万击倒在地。萨阿德随后跑回他的宝马车，大声叫小扎伊纳布也这样做。他猛地关上并锁上车门，半圆方向倒车，拼命试图逃离猛烈的攻击。
In the process, he clipped Sylvan Mollard. Léer. Sard's rear tire got stuck in a mound of dirt, leaving his family stranded. The shooter then approached the vehicle from their hiding place. With careful, callous precision, they shot Sard, Iqbal and Suhalla through the side windows. Both Sard and Iqbal were shot four times, while Suhela sustained three gunshots. All three of them were shot twice directly in the middle of the forehead. The killer then returned their attention to Silvan Malier, pulling the trigger four more times. They stood over his body, shooting him execution style directly between the eyes. Investigators weren't sure at what point seven-year-old Zainab was shot. Judging by the injuries to her
在此过程中，他撞到了西尔万·莫利埃。萨阿德的后轮胎卡在土堆里，导致他的家人被困。枪手随后从藏身处接近车辆。他们小心翼翼、冷酷无情地通过侧窗射杀了萨阿德、伊克巴尔和苏赫拉。萨阿德和伊克巴尔各中四枪，而苏赫拉中了三枪。他们三人都被直接击中前额中心两次。凶手随后将注意力转回西尔万·莫利埃，又扣动了四次扳机。他们站在他的尸体上方，以行刑方式直接射击他的双眼之间。调查人员不确定七岁的扎伊纳布是在什么时候中枪的。从她
head, the killer had likely either run out of bullets or their gun had jammed before they were able to finish what they started. Instead, they used the barrel of the gun to bash the child over the head. The entire ambush likely lasted less than 60 seconds. Of the 21 shots fired during that time, 17 of them had hit the victims. In the attack on Zainab, a piece of grip from the gun handle had broken off. Coupled with the bullet casings, this allowed investigators to identify the murder weapon as a semi-automatic Luger P-O-6. The Swiss model service pistol had been a standard issue to members of the Swiss Army and police in the 1920s and 30s. It was an odd choice for a shooting spree, the kind of gun more likely to be found in a museum or private collection rather than used to
头部的伤势来看，凶手很可能是在子弹用尽或枪支卡壳后，才无法完成他们开始的事情。相反，他们用枪管猛击孩子的头部。整个伏击过程可能持续不到60秒。在那段时间里发射的21发子弹中，有17发击中了受害者。在袭击扎伊纳布时，枪柄上的一块握把断裂了。加上弹壳，这使调查人员能够确定凶器是一把半自动鲁格P-06手枪。这种瑞士型号军用手枪在20世纪20年代和30年代是瑞士军队和警察的标准配置。对于一场枪击狂潮来说，这是一个奇怪的选择，这种枪更有可能在博物馆或私人收藏中找到，而不是被用来
commit a brutal crime. Despite its age, it was still considered to be an incredibly accurate and reliable weapon, allowing up to 48 shots to be fired in under 30 seconds. Only eight cartridges could be loaded at once. With 21 shots fired, this meant that the Le Martinez shooter had reloaded twice during the attack. Given that they'd managed to do so while hitting all of their targets and without hitting the body of the moving BMW, police were certain of one thing. Whoever was responsible was an experienced and skilled shooter who fully intended to hit each one of their victims. News of the slaying spread throughout the Annasie region where violent crimes were mostly unheard of.
犯下残忍的罪行。尽管年代久远，它仍被认为是一种极其精确和可靠的武器，允许在30秒内发射多达48发子弹。一次只能装填8发子弹。发射了21发子弹，这意味着勒马蒂内的枪手在袭击过程中重新装填了两次。鉴于他们设法在击中所有目标的同时，且没有击中移动的宝马车的车身，警方确定了一件事。无论谁负责，都是一名经验丰富且技术娴熟的射手，完全打算击中他们的每一位受害者。谋杀的消息传遍了阿纳西地区，那里几乎从未听说过暴力犯罪。
Shervalene and its surroundings were considered incredibly safe, the type of place where residents didn't bother to lock their doors. There were only 70 homes in Shervalin, making it easy for police to question every household. Other than Brad Martin, nobody had witnessed anything that could be of use to the investigation or had suspicions about who the perpetrator might be, except for a trio of forestry workers. As reported exclusively by BBC's Panorama program, one forestry worker was driving down Coom Deer Road shortly before the shootings when they passed Lehmartin Air parking area. To the left of the clearing, they saw a large motorcycle, pulled over on the side of the road.
谢尔瓦林及其周边地区被认为极其安全，是那种居民甚至懒得锁门的居住地。谢尔瓦林只有70户人家，警方很容易询问每一户人家。除了布雷特·马丁，没有人目睹任何对调查有用的事情，也没有人怀疑肇事者可能是谁，除了三名林业工人。正如英国广播公司（BBC）《全景》节目独家报道的那样，一名林业工人在此次枪击事件发生前不久开车沿库姆鹿路行驶，当时他们经过了勒马蒂内停车区。在空地的左侧，他们看到一辆大型摩托车停在路边。
It was black and white with panniers on the side. The driver was dressed all in black, including a distinct dark helmet with a visor that was pulled down, covering their face completely. As the forestry worker continued down the public portion of the road, they soon passed another vehicle, a metallic grey BMW four-wheel drive. They believed it to be British as it was right-hand drive. The car was in good, clean condition and was being driven by a slightly boarding male with dark skin. The forestry worker was taken aback by how fast the car was driving on the narrow road.
它是黑白相间的，侧面有行李箱。驾驶员全身穿着黑色，包括一个独特的深色头盔，面罩拉下，完全遮住了脸。当林业工人继续沿道路的公共部分行驶时，他们很快经过了另一辆车，一辆金属灰色的宝马四驱车。他们认为它是英国车，因为它是右舵驾驶。这辆车状况良好、干净，由一名皮肤黝黑、略显秃顶的男性驾驶。林业工人对这辆车在狭窄道路上行驶的速度之快感到吃惊。
Ten minutes later, two other forestry workers were coming down the restricted road above Le Matané when they too crossed paths with the large black and white motorcycle. Given that public vehicles were forbidden from entering this section of the road, they waved to the road. the motorcyclist down. The rider's helmet was distinct in that it had a hinged visor that could be opened sideways to allow the wearer to hold a conversation without having to remove their helmet. The rider pulled the visor across, revealing he was a white male with a goatee and heavy brow. He said nothing as the forestry workers told him to turn around and drive back down. Brett Martin, the cyclist who discovered the bodies, had also seen this motorcycle coming down the Coomdeer Road as he struggled up the hill just before 355pm.
十分钟后，另外两名林业工人从勒马蒂内上方的限制道路上下来，他们也与那辆大型黑白摩托车擦肩而过。鉴于公共车辆被禁止进入该路段，他们向摩托车手挥手示意。骑手的头盔很独特，因为它有一个铰链式面罩，可以向侧面打开，让佩戴者在不摘下头盔的情况下进行交谈。骑手拉开面罩，露出他是一名留着山羊胡、眉毛浓密的白人男性。当林业工人告诉他掉头开回去时，他一言不发。发现尸体的骑行者布雷特·马丁在下午3点55分前艰难爬坡时，也看到了这辆摩托车沿着库姆鹿路下来。
Brett didn't recall seeing the metallic grey BMW, but he did have a vague recollection of a large four-wheel drive passing him at some point along his journey. Based on these timings, it was deduced that Brett had stumbled upon the crime scene, within a mere minute of the shootings. He hadn't heard any of the gunshots because the sound had been masked by the white noise of the rushing river. The only people who had heard the shots
布雷特不记得看到过那辆金属灰色的宝马，但他确实模糊地记得在旅途中的某个时候有一辆大型四驱车超过了他。根据这些时间，推断出布雷特在枪击事件发生后仅仅一分钟就偶然发现了犯罪现场。他没有听到任何枪声，因为声音被湍急河流的白噪音掩盖了。唯一听到枪声的人
were a local father and son, but they hadn't given it much thought. Hunting season was coming up, so they just assumed hunters were outtesting their rifles. Neither Brat nor the trio of French hikers who arrived at the scene shortly after the shooting recalled seeing anyone passed them down the hands. hill. This presented two possibilities. Either the man on the motorcycle was the killer and he'd
是当地的一对父子，但他们并没有多想。狩猎季节快到了，所以他们只是认为猎人在测试他们的步枪。布雷特和在枪击事件后不久到达现场的三名法国徒步旅行者都不记得看到有人从山上下来。这提出了两种可能性。要么骑摩托车的人是凶手，即使在知道自己被发现后，他仍
brazenly fled via the public road even after knowing he'd been spotted in the area, or the killer was someone else entirely and they'd fled via the woods, or the restricted route just around the bend from Le Matinee. Although the rough narrow road was clearly marked with a no-entry sign, it was still easily accessible. A person on foot, motorcycle, bike or four-wheel drive could have made their way down the rugged terrain to the other side of the mountain within an hour. Even a regular car could have made the journey if the driver was willing to accept pothold damage to their vehicle. From there, there were plenty of possible escape routes with Italy and Switzerland just a short distance away.
厚颜无耻地通过公共道路逃离，要么凶手是完全的另一个人，他们通过树林逃离，或者通过勒马蒂内转弯处的限制路线逃离。虽然崎岖狭窄的道路上清楚地标有禁止通行标志，但它仍然很容易进入。步行、摩托车、自行车或四驱车的人可以在一小时内穿过崎岖的地形到达山的另一边。如果驾驶员愿意接受车辆的坑洼损坏，即使是普通汽车也可以完成这段旅程。从那里，有许多可能的逃生路线，意大利和瑞士距离很近。
Police considered whether the motorcyclist could have been working in conjunction with the metallic grey four-wheel drive. A suspect sketch was drawn up based on the forestry workers' recollection, but police decided to withhold the image out of fear that it could spook the motorcyclist and sent him on the run. Less than 48 hours after the shooting, the crime scene was teeming with local and international media. This was a major news story and the public were hungry for information. Local police had been sworn to silence and the only individual involved with the French
警方考虑了摩托车手是否可能与金属灰色四驱车协同工作。根据林业工人的回忆绘制了一张嫌疑人素描，但警方决定隐瞒这张图像，担心它会惊动摩托车手并让他逃跑。枪击事件发生不到48小时，犯罪现场就挤满了当地和国际媒体。这是一个重大的新闻故事，公众渴望信息。当地警察被宣誓保密，唯一参与法国
investigation who was allowed to speak publicly about the case was Anisei prosecutor Eric Mayur. Mayur confirmed to the press that the police were working hard to determine a motive. All they knew for certain was that, quote, It was clearly an act of extreme savagery, and it was obvious that who did this wanted to kill. The French president vowed that everything would be done to find the person responsible. Given that the crime was committed on French soil against British citizens, French authorities joined investigators from the UK to try and answer the prevailing question. Was this a random attack, or did someone want the Al Hilly family dead?
调查并获准公开谈论此案的人是阿纳西检察官埃里克·马约尔（Eric Mayur）。马约尔向媒体证实，警方正在努力确定动机。他们唯一确定的是，引用：“这显然是一种极度野蛮的行为，很明显，做这件事的人想要杀人。”法国总统发誓将尽一切努力找到肇事者。鉴于犯罪是在法国领土上针对英国公民实施的，法国当局加入了来自英国的调查人员，试图回答那个普遍存在的问题。这是一次随机袭击，还是有人想要阿尔-希利一家死？
Ad. Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. For Saad Al-Hilly, one of life's greatest pleasures was spending quality time with his family. He'd met his wife, Iqbal nine years prior in Abu Dhabi, where Iqbal had been living at the time. They married quickly and moved into Sard's childhood home in the British village of Claygate, where they settled down to raise a family.
广告。案件档案（Case File）稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持案件档案继续提供高质量的内容。对于萨阿德·阿尔-希利来说，生活中最大的乐趣之一就是与家人共度美好时光。他在九年前在阿布扎比遇到了他的妻子伊克巴尔，当时伊克巴尔住在那里。他们很快结婚并搬进了萨阿德在英国克莱盖特村的童年故居，在那里他们定居下来抚养家庭。
Iqbal put her career as a dentist on hold to their stay-at-home mum to their two young daughters. The trip to the French Alps had been a spur-of-the-moment decision. Sard had business to tend to in the Swiss city of Geneva, which was just across the border from Annasi. Even though Zainab and Zena were due to return to school after summer holidays, Sard recognized it as an opportunity for a short family getaway. He adored France and had stayed in the Alps region a few times before.
伊克巴尔搁置了她的牙医职业，成为两个年幼女儿的全职妈妈。去法国阿尔卑斯山的旅行是一个突发的决定。萨阿德有生意要在瑞士日内瓦处理，那里就在阿纳西边境对面。尽管扎伊纳布和泽娜在暑假后就要回学校上课，但萨阿德认为这是一个短暂家庭度假的机会。他热爱法国，之前曾几次住在阿尔卑斯山地区。
It also gave him an opportunity to take his beloved caravan out on the road. Saad worked as a freelance engineer and he had a hobby for tinkering with mechanical parts. He developed a passion for caravaning after he was. restored a damaged caravan to its former glory. He'd since purchased a new one and had jumped at any chance to use it. Sometimes he'd take his family to stay at the local campsite just 10 miles from their home, just to enjoy a change of scenery. The family invited Iqbal's mother, Suhela Al-Ala Al-Af, to join them on their last-minute French getaway. The 74-year-old lived in Sweden, but was staying with her other daughter who lived an hour away from the Elhillies in southern England.
这也让他有机会把心爱的房车开上路。萨阿德是一名自由职业工程师，他有摆弄机械零件的爱好。他在修复了一辆损坏的房车使其恢复昔日辉煌后，对房车旅行产生了热情。此后他买了一辆新的，并抓住任何机会使用它。有时他会带家人去离家仅10英里的当地露营地，只是为了享受环境的变化。这家人邀请了伊克巴尔的母亲苏赫拉·阿尔-阿拉夫加入他们最后一分钟的法国之旅。这位74岁的老人住在瑞典，但当时正与住在离阿尔-希利家一小时路程的英格兰南部的另一个女儿住在一起。
Once word got out that the victims lived in Claygate, the media attention in Britain was immense. Claygate was an affluent family-oriented suburb 14 miles southwest of London. A local family being the targets of an international shooting was sensational news. Both of Sard's parents had passed away in recent years, but, reporters gathered outside the flat of his only sibling, older brother Zahid Ah-Hilly. Zahid couldn't think of anyone who would want to harm Sard or his family. Likewise, other friends of the family confirmed there was nothing untoward in the Al-Hili household. Sard and Iqbal were both kind and gentle, and their children were happy and well-adjusted.
一旦受害者住在克莱盖特的消息传出，英国的媒体关注度就非常巨大。克莱盖特是一个位于伦敦西南14英里的富裕、以家庭为导向的郊区。当地家庭成为国际枪击事件的目标是轰动性的新闻。萨阿德的父母近年来都已去世，但记者们聚集在他唯一的兄弟，哥哥扎希德·阿尔-希利（Zahid Al-Hilly）的公寓外。扎希德想不出有谁会想伤害萨阿德或他的家人。同样，该家庭的其他朋友也证实阿尔-希利家中没有任何不妥之处。萨阿德和伊克巴尔都很善良温柔，他们的孩子也很快乐且适应良好。
However, there was one family member who raised some red flags. Iqbal's brother, Hader, lived in Sweden with their mother, Suhela, and was schizophrenic. As a result of his mental illness, reports revealed that Hader had a history of threatening and beating Suhela, and that she lived in constant fear of him. Investigators considered whether Hader's mental instability could have led him to orchestrate the shootings. They looked into his whereabouts at the time of the crime, only to learn that he'd been receiving psychiatric treatment in England when the murders occurred, giving him an airtight alibi.
然而，有一个家庭成员引起了一些危险信号。伊克巴尔的兄弟哈德尔（Hader）和他们的母亲苏赫拉住在瑞典，患有精神分裂症。据报道，由于他的精神疾病，哈德尔有威胁和殴打苏赫拉的历史，她一直生活在对他的恐惧中。调查人员考虑了哈德尔的精神不稳定是否可能导致他策划了枪击事件。他们调查了他在犯罪时的下落，结果得知他在谋杀发生时正在英国接受精神病治疗，这给了他一个无懈可击的不在场证明。
Although Sard had been living in the UK since he was a young boy and was legally considered a British citizen, his ethnic origins were examined in detail. Anisey prosecutor Eric Mayu told reporters the fact that he was born in Iraq, that he had family in Iraq. Of course that's something that is of interest and we are asking ourselves if there is a link, between that and his death. A search of the Alhili's caravan at Les Solitaire du Lac campsite revealed that Sard had been travelling with a laptop and several thumb drives. When investigators checked the contents, they found numerous files filled with technical data
虽然萨阿德从小就住在英国，在法律上被视为英国公民，但他的种族背景受到了详细审查。阿纳西检察官埃里克·马约尔告诉记者：“他出生在伊拉克，他在伊拉克有家人。当然，这是我们感兴趣的事情，我们正在问自己，这与他的死亡之间是否存在联系。”对阿尔-希利在勒索利泰尔杜拉克露营地的房车进行的搜查显示，萨阿德旅行时带着一台笔记本电脑和几个拇指驱动器。当调查人员检查内容时，他们发现了大量装满技术数据的文件
and sensitive information relating to some freelance work Sard had been doing for a British company that sold satellites. The data he'd saved went well beyond what was required for his. his job. His laptop also had tracking software installed on it, which meant anyone with access to it could trace his movements. Given his connections with Iraq, investigators considered whether Saad could have been selling the satellite technology and other industry secrets to countries who wanted to use them against the West. Perhaps he'd traded secrets and been killed to ensure his silence, or he'd refused to hand the information over and had been targeted as a result.
以及与萨阿德一直在为一家销售卫星的英国公司所做的自由职业工作相关的敏感信息。他保存的数据远远超出了他工作所需的内容。他的笔记本电脑还安装了跟踪软件，这意味着任何有权访问它的人都可以追踪他的行踪。鉴于他与伊拉克的联系，调查人员考虑萨阿德是否可能一直在向想要利用这些技术对抗西方的国家出售卫星技术和其他行业机密。也许他交易了秘密并被杀以确保他保持沉默，或者他拒绝交出信息并因此成为目标。
Sard's employers denied that he was involved with any confidential projects. There was nothing in his job that carried any risk, nor did it require him to sign the Official Secrets Act. Those who knew Sard were incredulous at the suggestion that he could be involved with industrial espionage. He was a hard-working devoted father who enjoyed cycling and playing badminton in his spare time and was always willing to help out a friend or neighbour in need. Sard was also outspoken and enjoyed debating his socio-political views, so he would have made a lousy spy. There was no way he was involved in top-secret work.
萨阿德的雇主否认他参与了任何机密项目。他的工作中没有任何风险，也不需要他签署《官方机密法》。那些认识萨阿德的人对暗示他可能参与工业间谍活动的说法表示怀疑。他是一位努力工作、尽职尽责的父亲，喜欢在业余时间骑自行车和打羽毛球，并且总是乐于帮助有需要的朋友或邻居。萨阿德也直言不讳，喜欢辩论他的社会政治观点，所以他会是一个糟糕的间谍。他不可能参与绝密工作。
But for Sard's neighbour, Philip, news of Sard's death immediately brought his him back to 2003. At the time, the US and British Armed Forces had just invaded Iraq. The police had approached Philip and asked if they could use his driveway to keep watch of the Alhili's home. They spent all day parked there, watching the house where Sard and his brother Zahid were living together at the time. Anytime Sard drove away, the undercover police followed him. Philip never knew why they were watching the brothers, nor did he ever warn them that they were being spied on, but it left him curious.
但对于萨阿德的邻居菲利普（Philip）来说，萨阿德去世的消息立刻让他回到了2003年。当时，美国和英国武装部队刚刚入侵伊拉克。警察曾找到菲利普，询问他们是否可以使用他的车道来监视阿尔-希利家。他们整天停在那里，监视着萨阿德和他的兄弟扎希德当时住在一起的房子。每当萨阿德开车离开时，便衣警察就跟着他。菲利普从不知道他们为什么要监视这对兄弟，也从未警告过他们正在被监视，但这让他感到好奇。
On Saturday, September 8, 2012, three days after the shootings, officers made their way inside the two-story mock tutor home belonging to the Alhili family. They confiscated various items of computer equipment. Sard had converted the garden shed behind the house into a makeshift office, and several potentially hazardous items were found inside that made officers nervous. The bomb squad was called in as a precautionary measure, and the property was
2012年9月8日星期六，枪击事件发生三天后，警官们进入了属于阿尔-希利家的两层仿都铎式住宅。他们没收了各种计算机设备。萨阿德将房子后面的花园棚改造成了一个临时办公室，里面发现了几件潜在的危险物品，这让警官们感到紧张。拆弹小组作为预防措施被召集，房产被
cordoned off while nearby residents were forced to evacuate. It was a false alarm. None of the items turned out to be dangerous. However, there were a couple of other things that raised suspicion. Inside the house, police found a taser. The weapon was illegal, and it seemed strange that a quiet family with no enemies would be armed with such a protective item. Furthermore, the locks on the house had recently been changed and a new security alarm system had been installed. Whatever the reason, it appeared that Sard Al-Hilly was nervous about something. As investigators hustled to piece together a clear picture of Sard and his background, seven-year-old Zainab El-Hilly woke up from her induced coma. The young girl was making a
封锁，附近的居民被迫撤离。这是一个虚惊一场。这些物品中没有一件是危险的。然而，还有其他几件事引起了怀疑。在房子里，警察发现了一把泰瑟枪。这种武器是非法的，对于一个没有敌人的安静家庭来说，配备这种防御性物品似乎很奇怪。此外，房子的锁最近被更换了，并安装了新的安全警报系统。无论原因是什么，萨阿德·阿尔-希利似乎对某事感到紧张。当调查人员忙于拼凑萨阿德及其背景的清晰图景时，七岁的扎伊纳布·阿尔-希利从诱导昏迷中醒来。这个小女孩正在
strong recovery but was still in a very delicate state. Investigators had to tread carefully when questioning her. Zanab recalled that on the day of the murders her father had asked what she'd rather do that day, go shopping in town or go for a walk in the woods. Zanab chose the latter. Beyond arriving at Le Martinet and getting out of the car with her father, Zainab didn't remember anything except seeing, quote, one bad man. Although she couldn't be sure, Zainab also thought she might have seen a silhouette. Zainab was given the green light to return to the UK. Both she and her younger sister Zina were held at a secret location
强力恢复，但仍处于非常脆弱的状态。调查人员在审讯她时必须小心谨慎。扎伊纳布回忆说，在谋杀发生的那天，她的父亲问她那天想做什么，去城里购物还是去树林里散步。扎伊纳布选择了后者。除了到达勒马蒂内并和父亲一起下车外，扎伊纳布不记得任何事情，除了看到，引用：“一个坏人。”虽然她不能确定，但扎伊纳布也认为她可能看到了一个轮廓。扎伊纳布获准返回英国。她和她的妹妹泽娜都被关押在一个秘密地点
and placed under strict police protection. Psychologists believed that Zainab likely remembered more about the attack but had been so traumatised that her brain couldn't yet process the information. Investigators had to accept that their star witness didn't hold the key to solving the crime. Instead, they sourced archive images of the Chervillene region from every satellite company in Europe and studied the stills from the day of the shootings. They obtained CCTV footage from the route the El Hilly family would have taken from Claygate to their campsite in France, combing through footage captured from gas stations, toll roads and ferry terminals for a glimpse of the family's maroon BMW.
并置于严格的警察保护之下。心理学家认为，扎伊纳布可能记得更多关于袭击的事情，但受到了太大的创伤，以至于她的大脑还无法处理这些信息。调查人员不得不接受他们的明星证人并没有掌握解决犯罪的关键。相反，他们从欧洲的每一家卫星公司搜集了谢尔瓦林地区的存档图像，并研究了枪击当天的静态照片。他们获得了阿尔-希利一家从克莱盖特到法国露营地可能走的路线的闭路电视录像，梳理了从加油站、收费公路和渡轮码头捕获的录像，以寻找这家人栗色宝马车的踪迹。
They compared still images to see if the BMW was being tailed, but at no point did the same vehicle appear behind the family twice. That didn't rule out the possibility that someone had tracked them. movements and followed them from their campsite up the Coom Deer Road. But had they done so, they would have had to have sound local knowledge of the area to be able to facilitate a quick getaway without being seen. Either the killer was a local, which also explained their use of a local firearm, or they'd done extensive research of the area beforehand. Eight days into the investigation, French prosecutor Eric Mayu told reporters that all of the Although the motive and perpetrator's identity remained unclear, there was no doubt that the reasons
他们比较了静态图像，看看宝马车是否被跟踪，但在任何时候，同一辆车都没有两次出现在这家人身后。这并没有排除有人跟踪他们行踪并从露营地一直跟随他们到库姆鹿路的可能性。但如果他们这样做了，他们必须具备该地区的扎实当地知识，才能在不被发现的情况下促进快速逃离。要么凶手是当地人，这也解释了他们使用当地枪支的原因，要么他们事先对该地区进行了广泛的研究。调查进行到第八天，法国检察官埃里克·马约尔告诉记者，尽管动机和肇事者的身份仍然不清楚，但毫无疑问，犯罪的理由
for the crime originated in England. The theory that Sard was involved with industrial espionage gained traction and became a gold mine for the British tabloids. While the authorities continued to follow this as a genuine possibility, another more plausible lead emerged. The previous September, Sard had written a letter to a childhood friend following the death of his father. In it, he talked about his relationship with his older brother, Zayed. Sard wrote,
起源于英国。萨阿德参与工业间谍活动的理论获得了关注，并成为英国小报的金矿。虽然当局继续将其作为一种真正的可能性进行追踪，但另一个更合理的线索出现了。前一年9月，萨阿德在父亲去世后写了一封信给一位童年朋友。在信中，他谈到了他与哥哥扎希德的关系。萨阿德写道：
Zaid and I do not communicate anymore, as he is another control freak and tried a lot of underhanded things even when my father was alive. He tried to take control of father's assets and demanded control. It's a long story, and I have just had to wipe him out of my life. Sad, but I need to concentrate now on my wife and two lovely girls. In contrast, Zahid Al-Hilly told the British investigators that he and his brother had a good relationship. After Zahid's wife passed away from ovarian cancer in 2007, Sard invited Zahid to temporarily move in with his wife and daughters in Claygate. Zahid's adult son had left home and Sard thought it would do his brother good to be surrounded by loved ones during his time of grief.
“扎希德和我不再交流了，因为他是另一个控制狂，即使在我父亲活着的时候也尝试了很多卑鄙的事情。他试图控制父亲的资产并要求控制权。这是一个很长的故事，我不得不把他从我的生活中抹去。很悲伤，但我现在需要专注于我的妻子和两个可爱的女儿。”相比之下，扎希德·阿尔-希利告诉英国调查人员，他和他的兄弟关系很好。在扎希德的妻子于2007年因卵巢癌去世后，萨阿德邀请扎希德暂时搬到克莱盖特与他的妻子和女儿住在一起。扎希德的成年儿子已经离家，萨阿德认为让他的兄弟在悲伤期间被亲人包围对他有好处。
Zaid ended up staying for over a year, during which he cherished getting to bond with Zainab and Zena. The brothers falling out was confirmed by other friends of Sarts. It all started when their father, Cardim Alhili, passed away in August 2011. At the time of his death, Cardim lived in Spain. He left his estate to his two sons who would receive, a 50-50 split of the Claygate home as well as Cardim's Spanish flat. Given that Saad and his family were already living in the Claygate property,
扎希德最终住了超过一年，在此期间，他珍惜与扎伊纳布和泽娜建立联系的机会。兄弟俩的不和得到了萨阿德其他朋友的证实。这一切始于他们的父亲卡迪姆·阿尔-希利（Cardim Alhili）于2011年8月去世时。在他去世时，卡迪姆住在西班牙。他将遗产留给了他的两个儿子，他们将获得克莱盖特住宅的50-50分成，以及卡迪姆的西班牙公寓。鉴于萨阿德和他的家人已经住在克莱盖特的房产中，
which was valued at around 800,000 pounds, Zahid wanted Saad to buy him out. Zahid also wanted to increase his share of the Spanish flat to 75%. Saad felt this was totally unfair and refused to accept Zahid's demands. Tensions asked him. escalated, and things came to a head in October of 2011. Zahid was still living in the Claygate home at the time, but was looking for his own place to move into. A physical altercation broke out between the two brothers that resulted in Sard calling the police.
该房产价值约80万英镑，扎希德希望萨阿德买下他的份额。扎希德还希望将他在西班牙公寓的份额增加到75%。萨阿德认为这完全不公平，拒绝接受扎希德的要求。紧张局势升级，事情在2011年10月达到了顶峰。扎希德当时仍住在克莱盖特的家中，但正在寻找自己的住处搬进去。两兄弟之间爆发了肢体冲突，导致萨阿德报了警。
Shortly after, Sard changed the locks. The brothers both obtained lawyers to represent their interests in their father's estate, and all future contact was handled by mediators. Sard ordered a freeze on his father's will, ensuring that Zahid couldn't claim any of the money until the dispute was resolved. In an online chat with his friend James, Sard called Zahid an asshole who was motivated by greed. He said he had reason to believe Zahid was involved in tax evasion and fraud and was prepared to use the information against Zaid if need be. Sard also told James that some valuable items went missing from his. home while Zahid was living there, which is why he changed the locks.
此后不久，萨德更换了门锁。兄弟俩各自聘请了律师来维护他们在父亲遗产中的利益，此后所有的联系都由调解人处理。萨德下令冻结了他父亲的遗嘱，确保在纠纷解决之前，扎希德无法领取任何钱财。在与朋友詹姆斯的在线聊天中，萨德称扎希德是个贪婪的混蛋。他说他有理由相信扎希德涉及逃税和欺诈，并准备在必要时利用这些信息对付扎希德。萨德还告诉詹姆斯，扎希德住在家里时，家里丢失了一些贵重物品，这就是他更换门锁的原因。
When Sard was killed, he hadn't spoken to his brother in almost a year. The fact that Zahid had initially told police that the two had a good relationship raised major red flags for investigators. When confronted with the evidence that indicated otherwise, Zahid conceded that there were financial disputes, but maintained that the two were otherwise close. He denied being involved in a feud with his brother, saying that their disagreement regarding money wasn't personal. Zahid had a verified alibi for the day of the murders. He had been at the seaside with a friend eating ice cream and browsing the local shops. While this proved Zahid wasn't
萨德遇害时，他已经有近一年没有和哥哥说话了。扎希德最初告诉警方两人关系良好，这一事实引起了调查人员的极大怀疑。当面对表明事实并非如此的证据时，扎希德承认他们之间存在经济纠纷，但坚称两人关系依然亲密。他否认与哥哥有宿怨，称他们关于金钱的分歧并非针对个人。扎希德有案发当天的确凿不在场证明。他当时和一位朋友在海边吃冰淇淋并逛当地的商店。虽然这证明了扎希德不是
the one who pulled the trigger, it led police to question whether he could have organized someone else to carry out the attack on his behalf. The slayings had all the hallmarks of a professional hit, a precise experienced gunman firing rounds into the foreheads of each of his victims. But if Zayed and Sard weren't talking, how would a hired killer know to find the Al-Hili's in that secluded part of the French Alps? The Luger pistol was the only tangible clue, but there were roughly 30,000 of these weapons in Switzerland alone. Given that the murder scene was 30 miles from the Swiss border and the gun used was Swiss, authorities in Geneva were also brought in to assist.
那个扣动扳机的人，但这让警方质疑他是否可能组织了其他人代他实施袭击。这起谋杀案具有职业杀手的所有特征：一名精准、经验丰富的枪手向每位受害者的前额开枪。但如果扎希德和萨德不说话，雇佣杀手怎么会知道在法国阿尔卑斯山那个偏僻的地方找到阿尔-希利一家呢？鲁格手枪是唯一的实物线索，但仅在瑞士就有大约30,000支这种武器。鉴于案发现场距离瑞士边境30英里，且使用的枪支是瑞士制造的，日内瓦当局也被请来协助调查。
They discovered that the business Sard Al-Hili intended to take care of in Switzerland related to a private bank account held in his father's name. Sard had called the bank on Monday, two days before his death, and spoke of his intentions to visit. This was noteworthy, given there had been questioned. activity on the account in the past. Sard's father, Cardim Alhili, had set up the account in 1988, making a sizable deposit that was now worth close to 1 million euros. The account had barely been touched since, which is why
他们发现萨德·阿尔-希利打算在瑞士处理的业务与他父亲名下的一个私人银行账户有关。萨德在去世前两天，即周一给银行打了电话，并谈到了他访问的意图。考虑到过去该账户曾出现过可疑活动，这一点值得注意。萨德的父亲卡迪姆·阿尔-希利于1988年开设了该账户，并存入了一笔巨款，现在价值接近100万欧元。此后该账户几乎没有动过，这就是为什么
one bank employee flagged it as strange when someone in England applied for a credit card linked to the account just one year before Cardin passed away. The employee examined the application form and noticed that the applicant's signature differed from the one they had on file. The bank contacted Khadim, who denied ever making the request. A Swiss prosecutor publicly stated that the person who fraudulently tried to acquire the credit card was none other than Zayid al-Hili. He claimed that Zahid had forged his father's signature in an attempt to gain access to the money in the Geneva account.
一名银行职员在卡迪姆去世前一年，当有人在英国申请与该账户关联的信用卡时，将其标记为异常。职员检查了申请表，发现申请人的签名与他们存档的签名不同。银行联系了卡迪姆，他否认曾提出过该请求。一位瑞士检察官公开表示，那个试图欺诈获取信用卡的人正是扎希德·阿尔-希利。他声称扎希德伪造了他父亲的签名，试图获取日内瓦账户里的钱。
Speaking to journalist Tom Parry for his book The Perfect Crime, Zahid strongly denied this allegation, maintaining that his father had been the one who applied for the credit card. Regardless, the revelation that the Aarhili's had a so-called secret bank account in Switzerland immediately added to the speculation surrounding the case. If the family had nothing to hide, some wondered why they were squirreling money away in an offshore account. Six and a half weeks after the shootings, Sard, Iqbal and Suhela were laid to rest in a private ceremony held in the Shia Muslim section of Brookwood Cemetery, 20 miles north of Claygate, with armed guards keeping watch.
在为他的书《完美犯罪》接受记者汤姆·帕里采访时，扎希德强烈否认了这一指控，坚称是他的父亲申请了那张信用卡。无论如何，阿尔-希利一家在瑞士拥有所谓秘密银行账户的披露，立即增加了围绕此案的猜测。一些人想知道，如果这个家庭没有什么可隐瞒的，为什么要把钱藏在离岸账户里。枪击事件发生六周半后，萨德、伊克巴尔和苏海拉被安葬在克莱盖特以北20英里处布鲁克伍德公墓的什叶派穆斯林区，并有武装警卫守卫。
Days later, readers of French newspaper Le Monde opened their papers to find the sensational headline, the potential links between the Alhili's and Saddam Hussein. According to the article, the Swiss bank account had led the German Secret Service to uncover a link between Cardim Al-Hilly and the former Iraqi dictator. Shortly before Saddam Hussein's execution in 2006, he reportedly withdrew over £600 million pounds from the Iraqi Central Bank and deposited in secret bank accounts around the world, including Switzerland. The money smuggling was thought to be assisted by a money-smuggling. Iraqi nationals who lived abroad. Le Monde theorized that Khadim could have worked as one of Saddam Hussein's
几天后，法国《世界报》的读者打开报纸，看到了耸人听闻的标题：阿尔-希利一家与萨达姆·侯赛因之间潜在的联系。据文章称，瑞士银行账户促使德国情报部门发现了卡迪姆·阿尔-希利与这位前伊拉克独裁者之间的联系。据报道，在萨达姆·侯赛因2006年被处决前不久，他从伊拉克中央银行提取了超过6亿英镑，并存入世界各地的秘密银行账户，包括瑞士。洗钱活动被认为是由居住在国外的伊拉克国民协助完成的。法国《世界报》推测，卡迪姆可能曾担任萨达姆·侯赛因的
conduits and Assad had gotten himself killed by trying to access the money. Those close to the El-Hili family scoffed at what they saw to be malicious rumors. It was because of Saddam Hussein's regime that the Al-Hilis had been forced to flee Iraq in the first place. Cardim had been a successful lawyer turned businessman, he'd amassed a healthy profit selling tissue paper and poultry. Any money he'd hidden away was well and truly earned. To suggest he'd helped launder money for the dictator was hurtful to the surviving relatives. This wild theory quickly disappeared from the headlines, but it contributed to the growing narrative that Sard was involved in some kind of nefarious activity that had contributed to the murders. It was also revealed that
渠道之一，而萨德因试图获取这笔钱而丧命。那些与阿尔-希利家族关系密切的人对他们所认为的恶意谣言嗤之以鼻。正是因为萨达姆·侯赛因的政权，阿尔-希利一家才被迫逃离伊拉克。卡迪姆曾是一名成功的律师，后来转行经商，他通过销售纸巾和家禽积累了可观的利润。他隐藏的任何钱都是真正赚来的。暗示他曾帮助独裁者洗钱，这对幸存的亲属来说是伤害。这个疯狂的理论很快从头条新闻中消失了，但它助长了一种日益增长的说法，即萨德参与了某种导致谋杀的邪恶活动。还有人透露，
that he'd held some radical political beliefs which he'd shared online in various Arabic chat forums. This led to public speculation that Sard could have been the victim of a state-sponsored assassination, a theory fuelled by the fact that both Sard and Iqbal's passports were still nowhere to be found. Police had searched their home, car and caravan, as well as police stations lost and found officers and hotels along the route the Alhili family had taken on their. holiday, but the passports had mysteriously disappeared. Some speculated that the killer could have taken them as some kind of trophy or proof of their hit. Similar assassinations had been carried out in the past, but those involved had been associated
他持有的一些激进政治信仰曾在各种阿拉伯聊天论坛上分享。这引发了公众的猜测，即萨德可能是国家支持的暗杀受害者，这一理论因萨德和伊克巴尔的护照至今下落不明而得到进一步推波助澜。警方搜查了他们的家、汽车和房车，以及沿途的警察局失物招领处和酒店，但护照神秘地消失了。一些人推测，凶手可能将它们作为某种战利品或行凶证据拿走了。过去也曾发生过类似的暗杀事件，但那些涉案人员都与
with weaponry development or the military and were deemed to be a threat to national security. There was nothing in Sard's background to indicate he fit this bill. Furthermore, if a hitman really did want Sard dead, it didn't make sense that they would also attack his wife, mother-in-law and children. While some investigators were convinced that the crime had the hallmarks of a contract killing, others thought otherwise. If the killer was a professional, skeptics to the hitman theory wondered why the shooter had used such an antiquated weapon. The fact that they'd managed not to hit the moving BAMW proved their proficiency as a shooter, but their first shots had missed Sard when he was standing outside of the vehicle. If Sard really was the intended target, the shooter had botched the hit from the very beginning.
武器开发或军队有关，并被视为对国家安全构成威胁。萨德的背景中没有任何迹象表明他符合这一条件。此外，如果杀手真的想让萨德死，那么他们同时袭击他的妻子、岳母和孩子就说不通了。虽然一些调查人员确信这起犯罪具有雇佣杀手的特征，但其他人则有不同看法。如果凶手是专业的，怀疑雇佣杀手理论的人会问，为什么枪手使用了如此过时的武器。他们设法没有击中移动的宝马车证明了他们作为射手的熟练程度，但他们的第一枪在萨德站在车外时却打偏了。如果萨德真的是预定目标，那么枪手从一开始就搞砸了这次暗杀。
Also, Sard, Iqbal and Suhela had all been stuck in the car, making them easy targets for the gunmen standing directly outside. Anyone with decent firearm proficiency was capable of shooting them at such close range. Investigators considered whether Sard could have been lured to Lourg-Martiné by someone under false pretences. His phone and emails records were checked, but nothing was found to indicate a pre-planned meeting. A guest who was staying at the same campsite as the Alhilies recalled seeing Sard having a heated exchange with a man of Balkan appearance. Although this interaction couldn't be verified, it fuelled speculation that a contract killer could have travelled from the former Yugoslavia. It was rumoured that Eastern European hitmen could
此外，萨德、伊克巴尔和苏海拉都被困在车里，这使他们成为站在车外直接射击的枪手的容易目标。任何具有一定枪支熟练度的人都有能力在如此近的距离内射杀他们。调查人员考虑萨德是否可能被某人以虚假借口诱骗到卢尔-马蒂内。他的电话和电子邮件记录都经过了检查，但没有发现任何迹象表明有预先计划的会面。一位住在同一露营地的客人回忆说，看到萨德与一名巴尔干长相的男子发生了激烈的争执。虽然这种互动无法证实，但这助长了合同杀手可能来自前南斯拉夫的猜测。有传言称，东欧杀手可以
reportedly be hired on the dark web for as little as a few hundred pounds. These men had been hardened during armed conflicts and some were willing to use their lethal expertise for financial gain. It was possible that a master contract killer could have travelled to France via road, executed the hit, and then disappeared back into their home country as quickly as they came without drawing any attention to themselves. For investigators, the financial dispute between the Alhili brothers gave Zahid a compelling motive to want Sard and his family out of the picture. But if Zahid had hired someone to perform the hit,
据报道，在暗网上以低至几百英镑的价格被雇佣。这些人曾在武装冲突中磨练过，有些人愿意为了经济利益利用他们的致命专业知识。有可能是一名职业合同杀手通过公路前往法国，执行了暗杀，然后像来时一样迅速消失回自己的国家，而没有引起任何人的注意。对于调查人员来说，阿尔-希利兄弟之间的经济纠纷给了扎希德一个令人信服的动机，让他想要除掉萨德一家。但如果扎希德雇佣了某人来执行暗杀，
why hadn't the gunman completed the job by killing Zainab and Zina? The surviving daughters would inherit Sard's estate, meaning Zaid had very little to gain. While all of these theories were compelling, none of them quite added up. This left investigators with no choice but to consider another possibility entirely. What if Sard wasn't the intended target after all? Case File will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads.
为什么枪手没有通过杀死扎伊纳布和齐娜来完成任务？幸存的女儿们将继承萨德的遗产，这意味着扎希德几乎没有什么可获得的。虽然所有这些理论都很引人注目，但没有一个完全说得通。这使得调查人员别无选择，只能完全考虑另一种可能性。如果萨德根本不是预定目标呢？Case File节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本节目的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本节目的广告。
By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Iqbal Al-Hilly had become a secondary player in this giant media story that centered mostly around her husband. At first glance, she was a quiet, reserved stay-at-home mother who put great importance on her Muslim faith. But as police looked into Iqbal's background, they discovered she harboured a secret. On Sard and Iqbal's marriage certificate, Iqbal listed herself as previously unmarried. But this wasn't true. Not only had Iqbal been married before, she was still legally married at the time that she and Sard tied the night in 2003. In 1999, Iqbal had moved to the United States to the United States to pursue a dentistry job.
通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。伊克巴尔·阿尔-希利在这个主要围绕她丈夫展开的巨大媒体故事中成为了一个次要角色。乍一看，她是一位安静、矜持的家庭主妇，非常重视她的穆斯林信仰。但当警方调查伊克巴尔的背景时，他们发现她隐藏了一个秘密。在萨德和伊克巴尔的结婚证书上，伊克巴尔将自己列为未婚。但这并非事实。伊克巴尔不仅以前结过婚，而且在2003年她和萨德结婚时，她在法律上仍然处于婚姻状态。1999年，伊克巴尔搬到了美国，从事牙科工作。
Before long, a friend introduced her to a man named to Jimmy Thompson, an oil worker and Harley Davidson enthusiast 20 years her senior. The two hit it off and married quickly. Iqbal moved into Jimmy's house in Louisiana, where she embraced a Western lifestyle. She went by the name Kelly and spent her spare time running and barbecuing with Jimmy's family by the pool. Iqbal and Jimmy were happily married for 18 months, after which Iqbal suddenly left the US and returned to Abu Dhabi.
没过多久，一位朋友把她介绍给了一个名叫吉米·汤普森的人，他是一名石油工人和哈雷戴维森爱好者，比她大20岁。两人一拍即合，很快就结婚了。伊克巴尔搬进了吉米在路易斯安那州的房子，在那里她拥抱了西方生活方式。她改名叫凯利，闲暇时和吉米的家人在游泳池边跑步和烧烤。伊克巴尔和吉米幸福地结婚了18个月，之后伊克巴尔突然离开美国回到了阿布扎比。
Some believe she was simply homesick, while others think she was under pressure from her family to marry a Muslim man and take on a more traditional role. It has also been speculated that her marriage to Jimmy was purely one of convenience, so that Iqbal could obtain a US green card. Whatever the reason, it wasn't long before Iqbal and Sard were reportedly introduced by family members as part of a mutually agreed-upon arranged marriage. As far as any of the Al-Hili's friends in England were aware, Saad had no idea that he was Iqbal's second husband. They were shocked to learn that Iqbal had lived a westernized, somewhat outgoing life in the United States, as this was completely out of character for the conservative woman they knew.
有些人认为她只是想家了，而另一些人则认为她在家庭压力下不得不嫁给一名穆斯林男子并承担更传统的角色。还有人推测，她与吉米的婚姻纯粹是为了方便，以便伊克巴尔获得美国绿卡。无论原因如何，没过多久，据报道，伊克巴尔和萨德就由家庭成员介绍，作为双方同意的包办婚姻的一部分。据英国的阿尔-希利家族朋友所知，萨德根本不知道他是伊克巴尔的第二任丈夫。他们震惊地得知伊克巴尔在美国过着西化、有些外向的生活，因为这与他们所认识的保守女性形象完全不符。
In England, she mostly kept to herself and was incredibly shy. She didn't even drive or go out to do the shopping. Investigators were curious to learn why Iqbal had suddenly departed from the United States. They attempted to make contact with the Jimmy Thompson in Louisiana, only to make another shocking discovery. Jimmy had passed away on the very very very. very same day that Iqbal had been killed. Medical records stated that the overweight Jimmy had died of a heart attack while driving, but when his family learned that Iqbal had been murdered just
在英国，她大多独来独往，非常害羞。她甚至不开车，也不出去购物。调查人员很好奇为什么伊克巴尔突然离开美国。他们试图联系路易斯安那州的吉米·汤普森，却有了另一个惊人的发现。吉米去世的那一天，正是伊克巴尔被杀的那一天。医疗记录显示，超重的吉米在开车时死于心脏病发作，但当他的家人得知伊克巴尔在几个小时前被谋杀时，他们开始提出疑问。吉米从未进行过正式尸检，所以如果他根本不是死于自然原因呢？正如《完美犯罪》一书中所报道的那样，吉米的妹妹朱迪知道伊克巴尔和吉米一直通过电子邮件保持联系。这与英国阿尔-希利家族朋友的报告相矛盾，他们说伊克巴尔是一个技术恐惧症患者，拒绝让萨德为她设置电子邮件地址。据朱迪说，当她去检查吉米的电子邮件时，他所有的信息都被删除了。
hours beforehand, they began to ask questions. An official autopsy had never been conducted on Jimmy, so what if he hadn't died of natural causes after all? As reported in the book The Perfect Crime, Jimmy's sister Judy was aware that Iqbal and Jimmy's had kept in touch via email. This contradicted reports from the Alhili's friends in England who said Iqbal was a technophobe who refused to let Sard set her up with an email address. According to Judy, when she went to check Jimmy's email, all of his messages had been erased.
（注：原文第65块内容与第64块有重复，此处按原文逻辑翻译）
The FBI got involved to explore the possibility that Jimmy Thompson's death was somehow linked to his ex-wife's murder. They even considered exhuming his wife's murder. body to conduct an official autopsy, but ultimately there was nothing to support the theory that Jimmy's death was connected to the French shooting. The fact that both he and his ex-wife had both died on the same day was deemed a mere coincidence. Regardless, the fact that Iqbal had managed to conceal a secret marriage left some wondering what other secrets she might be hiding. Very little was known about Iqbal's mother, Suhela Al-Alaf,
联邦调查局介入调查吉米·汤普森的死是否与他前妻的谋杀案有关。他们甚至考虑挖掘他的尸体进行正式尸检，但最终没有任何证据支持吉米的死与法国枪击案有关的理论。他和他的前妻在同一天去世的事实被认为纯属巧合。无论如何，伊克巴尔成功隐瞒了一段秘密婚姻的事实，让一些人想知道她还可能隐藏着什么其他秘密。关于伊克巴尔的母亲苏海拉·阿尔-阿拉夫知之甚少，
The 74-year-old widowed mother of four lived in the suburbs of Stockholm, having moved to Sweden from Iraq in the mid-1980s with her husband, Abdul, and their son, Haydar. She was reportedly a quiet and private person. Investigators hadn't been able to ascertain the exact reason why she had decided to join the Alhili's on their last-minute French holiday. Due to her age and the limited background information about her, Suhela wasn't. an obvious choice when it came to investigators trying to determine which one of the victims had been the intended target. But some suspicious elements quickly emerged that meant she couldn't be crossed off entirely. According to the book The Perfect Crime, a search of Suhela's personal computer revealed that it was fitted with spyware. This meant that whoever had access to the spyware
这位74岁的丧偶母亲有四个孩子，住在斯德哥尔摩郊区，她于80年代中期与丈夫阿卜杜勒和儿子海达尔从伊拉克搬到瑞典。据报道，她是一个安静且注重隐私的人。调查人员一直无法确定她决定参加阿尔-希利一家最后一分钟的法国假期的确切原因。由于她的年龄和关于她的背景信息有限，当调查人员试图确定哪位受害者是预定目标时，苏海拉并不是一个明显的选择。但一些可疑因素很快浮出水面，这意味着她不能完全被排除在外。据《完美犯罪》一书称，对苏海拉个人电脑的搜索显示，电脑上安装了间谍软件。这意味着任何能够访问该间谍软件的人
was able to remotely view every move that Suhela made on the computer. installing the software would have required technological skills that Suhela wasn't known to possess. This raised the question of why anyone would want to keep tabs on the elderly woman's online movements. Bank records didn't reveal her to be a wealthy woman, which made it even more confusing when Suhela's home in Sweden was ransacked in the aftermath of the shootings. Several items were stolen, including an assortment of personal documents and bank records. Investigators weren't prepared to close the door on any lines of inquiry, but the possibility that Sue Hela was the target and her daughter's family somehow got tied up in it, went to the bottom of the list.
都能够远程查看苏海拉在电脑上的每一个动作。安装该软件需要苏海拉并不具备的技术技能。这就提出了一个问题：为什么有人想监视这位老妇人的在线活动。银行记录显示她并不是一个富有的女人，这使得苏海拉在瑞典的家在枪击事件后被洗劫一空时更加令人困惑。几件物品被盗，包括各种个人文件和银行记录。调查人员不准备关闭任何调查方向，但苏海拉是目标而她女儿一家以某种方式被牵连进来的可能性，被排在了名单的最底层。
Another possibility was much more plausible. From the outset of the investigation, the family of the murdered cyclist Silvan Moliere had requested complete privacy to mourn his loss in peace. Because of this, very little was known about him. French investigators were confident that Silvan had just happened to be at the wrong place at the wrong time. Others weren't so sure. Silvan had sustained more gunshots than any other victim, five in total, and he was the only victim who lived locally. For British investigators, it therefore made sense to consider that Silvan could have been the target.
另一种可能性要合理得多。从调查一开始，被谋杀的骑自行车者西尔万·莫利埃的家人就要求完全保密，以便平静地哀悼他的离世。因此，关于他的情况知之甚少。法国调查人员确信西尔万只是恰好在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点。其他人则不那么确定。西尔万受到的枪伤比任何其他受害者都多，总共五处，而且他是唯一住在当地的受害者。因此，对于英国调查人员来说，考虑西尔万可能是目标是合理的，
while the Alhili's were collateral damage, instead of the other way around. Until having recently taken an extended period of paternity leave, Silvan Moliere worked at Sezuse, a factory just outside of Anasi that produced a nuclear components. Some wondered whether Silvan could have been selling nuclear secrets to other nations and had gotten in over his head, or angered an enemy who wanted to put a stop to his involvement. It was even speculated that Silvan knew Sard, and the two were conspiring together to sell both their satellite and nuclear secrets. But Silvan simply worked as a welder for Sezuse. He wasn't privy to any classified information.
而阿尔-希利一家是附带损害，而不是反过来。在最近休了很长一段时间的陪产假之前，西尔万·莫利埃在安纳西郊外的一家生产核部件的工厂Sezuse工作。有些人想知道西尔万是否可能一直在向其他国家出售核机密，并因此陷入了困境，或者激怒了一个想要阻止他参与的敌人。甚至有人推测西尔万认识萨德，两人正在密谋出售他们的卫星和核机密。但西尔万只是Sezuse的一名焊工。他没有接触任何机密信息的权限。
There was nothing in his phone or email records to indicate that he'd arranged to meet anyone at Le Matanet, nor was there any evidence that he and Sard had ever crossed paths before. It also turned out that Sard wasn't the only one allegedly embroiled in a bit of feud over money. The Sunday Times newspaper looked into Silvan's background and discovered that his partner, Claire, was from a wealthy local family. Claire had recently received ownership of her father's pharmacy, which was valued at just over one million pounds. According to the newspaper, Claire's family felt that Sylvan was taking advantage of their wealth
他的电话或电子邮件记录中没有任何迹象表明他曾安排在勒马塔内与任何人会面，也没有任何证据表明他和萨德之前曾有过交集。事实证明，萨德并不是唯一一个据称卷入金钱纠纷的人。《星期日泰晤士报》调查了西尔万的背景，发现他的伴侣克莱尔来自一个富有的当地家庭。克莱尔最近获得了她父亲药店的所有权，该药店价值略高于一百万英镑。据该报报道，克莱尔的家人觉得西尔万在利用他们的财富，
and sponging off their daughter. When Silvan announced he was going to be taking up to three years off work and effectively living off Claire's income, tensions reached a boiling point. On the day of the shooting, Claire's father recommended Silvan take the route up Coom Deer. French investigators considered the possibility that this could have been part of an intentional plan to rid Silvan of any claim to the family fortune. But Claire's family weren't nearly as well off as reporters had claimed. Claire hadn't been given the pharmacy.
并靠他们女儿的收入生活。当西尔万宣布他将休假长达三年，实际上靠克莱尔的收入生活时，紧张局势达到了沸点。在枪击发生的那天，克莱尔的父亲建议西尔万走库姆迪尔路线。法国调查人员考虑了这可能是为了剥夺西尔万对家族财富的任何索赔权而进行的蓄意计划的一部分的可能性。但克莱尔的家人并不像记者所说的那样富有。克莱尔并没有得到那家药店。
She had taken a loan out from her father and was paying it back slowly. Furthermore, she and Sylvan weren't married, meaning he wouldn't have been legally entitled to any of her money. The theory was ruled out. It was impossible for forensic investigators to determine which of the four victims had been shot first, But in one interpretation, Silvan had sustained the first bullet. If true, it was logical to assume that he could have been the intended target. But if money wasn't the issue, what was?
她从父亲那里借了一笔贷款，正在慢慢偿还。此外，她和西尔万没有结婚，这意味着他在法律上无权获得她的任何钱财。该理论被排除了。法医调查人员无法确定四名受害者中哪一位先被枪杀，但在一种解释中，西尔万承受了第一颗子弹。如果属实，假设他可能是预定目标是合乎逻辑的。但如果金钱不是问题所在，那是什么呢？
A friend of Silvan spoke to French newspaper Lissau Savoyar on the condition of anonymity. They claimed that Silvan was known to be a bit of a ladies' man. According to the friend, Silvan had once confided that, quote, He felt he had to be careful while walking down the street because he feared he would be shot. French investigators considered whether Silvan could have been killed by a jealous spouse in a crime of passion, but there was no evidence to indicate that his behaviour extended beyond harmless flirtation. Anisee prosecutor Eric Mayu told journalist Tom Parry, We have examined his life from every possible angle in every aspect, and we have found nothing
西尔万的一位朋友在匿名条件下向法国报纸《Lissau Savoyar》透露。他们声称西尔万以有点风流而闻名。据这位朋友说，西尔万曾经吐露说，引用：“他觉得走在街上时必须小心，因为他担心自己会被枪杀。”法国调查人员考虑西尔万是否可能被嫉妒的配偶在激情犯罪中杀害，但没有证据表明他的行为超出了无害的调情。安纳西检察官埃里克·马尤告诉记者汤姆·帕里：“我们从每一个可能的角度和每一个方面检查了他的生活，我们没有发现任何东西
which explains to us why anyone would want to get at this man. The French remained convinced that the answer to all their questions most likely lay with the British victims, but after extensive investigations, another credible theory started to gain serious What if no one had been targeted, and all of the victims had simply been in the wrong place at the wrong time? It was entirely possible that a lone mentally ill gunmen familiar with the area might have been lurking in weight, ready to launch an attack on whoever was unfortunate enough to stumble upon Le Martinet first. It might have been entirely coincidental that a carload of people and a lone cyclist just so happened to arrive at the same time.
这向我们解释了为什么有人会想对这个人下手。法国人仍然确信，他们所有问题的答案很可能在于英国受害者，但在经过广泛调查后，另一个可信的理论开始引起严重关注。如果根本没有人被针对，所有受害者只是在错误的时间出现在了错误的地点呢？完全有可能是一个熟悉该地区的精神病枪手潜伏在附近，准备对任何不幸先闯入勒马塔内的人发动袭击。一车人和一名骑自行车者恰好同时到达可能完全是巧合。
If the murders were the result of a random opportunistic attack, the perpetrator's firearm proficiency indicated they might have been ex-military or a member of law enforcement and legally licensed to own a gun. Investigators in both France and Switzerland examined psychiatric records on the lookout for anyone with a military background who also displayed homicidal tendencies. They tracked down recently released patients with prior convictions for gun violence or access to weapons, but didn't find anyone who fit the bill. Police also considered the possibility that the motorcyclist and the occupant of the mysterious
如果谋杀案是随机机会性袭击的结果，肇事者的枪支熟练程度表明他们可能是前军人或执法人员，并且合法拥有枪支。法国和瑞士的调查人员检查了精神病记录，寻找任何有军事背景且表现出杀人倾向的人。他们追踪了最近释放的、有枪支暴力前科或能接触到武器的病人，但没有发现任何符合条件的人。警方还考虑了摩托车手和神秘的
four-wheel drive had met at Le Matanet to complete a drug deal or other illegal handover. Both Silvan and the Al-Hillies might have unexpectedly disturbed the transaction and been killed as a result. This theory was quickly ruled out as the sleepy, remote town of Chevoline was a highly unlikely place for a serious drug deal. In France, there were ongoing tensions between the Muslim, Christian and Jewish communities, which led to speculation that the murders were an Islamophobic hate crime. Some theorise that a local racist experienced with firearms might have simply spotted the Al-Hili family holidaying in Lake Anasi
四轮驱动车驾驶员在勒马塔内会面以完成毒品交易或其他非法移交的可能性。西尔万和阿尔-希利一家可能意外地打断了交易并因此被杀。这一理论很快被排除，因为安静、偏远的切沃林镇不太可能是进行重大毒品交易的地方。在法国，穆斯林、基督徒和犹太社区之间存在持续的紧张关系，这导致人们猜测谋杀案是伊斯兰恐惧症仇恨犯罪。一些人推测，一名有枪支经验的当地种族主义者可能只是发现了在安纳西湖度假的阿尔-希利一家，
and singled them out due to their Middle Eastern background. But if this was the case, it didn't fit the typical bill for this type of attack. If the gunman was motivated by race or religion, investigators expected that they would have taken credit for the shootings in some capacity. Whatever the truth, prosecutor Mayhew concluded to GQ magazine that the target, quote, was one, the other, or neither. Months passed with over 40 officers dedicated to the case.
并因为他们的中东背景而将他们挑了出来。但如果是这种情况，它并不符合此类袭击的典型特征。如果枪手是出于种族或宗教动机，调查人员预计他们会以某种方式为枪击事件负责。无论真相如何，检察官马尤在接受《GQ》杂志采访时总结道，目标“是其中一个、另一个，或者都不是”。几个月过去了，有40多名警官致力于此案。
Despite the thorough investigation, all police had were unsubstantiated theories. The public remained gripped, with all the wild stories about spies, assassinations and foreign secrets becoming the perfect fodder for tabloid headlines. By April 2013, seven months had passed with no breakthroughs in the case. French investigators remained convinced that the Al-Hili connection held the key to solving the crime. Zaid Al-Hili was re-interviewed. he maintained that the fallout with his brother had been nothing more than a financial discrepancy
尽管进行了彻底的调查，警方所拥有的只是未经证实的理论。公众仍然被吸引，所有关于间谍、暗杀和外国机密的疯狂故事成为了小报头条的完美素材。到2013年4月，七个月过去了，案件没有任何突破。法国调查人员仍然确信阿尔-希利家族的联系是破案的关键。扎伊德·阿尔-希利再次接受了采访。他坚持认为与他哥哥的矛盾只不过是经济上的分歧，
for which he held no significant grudge. He said he loved Sard and was heartbroken by the tragedy, which he wanted solved as much as anyone. But when Zayyid was summoned to France to act as a witness, he flat out refused. Zahid was vocal about his distrust for the French authorities. He felt they were using the financial matters between himself and Sussie. to deflect from the truth, that the crime had its origins in France. If Zaid travelled across the English Channel, he feared the authorities would find a way to plant his DNA at the crime scene. Zaid told GQ Magazine,
他对此并没有怀恨在心。他说他爱萨德，并对这场悲剧感到心碎，他像任何人一样希望案件得到解决。但当扎伊德被传唤到法国担任证人时，他断然拒绝了。扎伊德直言不讳地表达了他对法国当局的不信任。他觉得他们正在利用他和萨德之间的经济问题来转移真相，即犯罪起源于法国。如果扎伊德穿过英吉利海峡，他担心当局会找到办法在他的DNA上做手脚，将其留在犯罪现场。扎伊德告诉《GQ》杂志，
To be honest with you, if the French authorities told me the sunrises in the east and sets in the west, I would think they were lying. Zahid wasn't legally obligated to obey the French summons unless they had compelling evidence, against him, so at the advice of his lawyer, he ignored it completely. This did nothing but add weight to the suspicion against him. If Zahid had nothing to hide, the belief was that he'd do anything to assist with the investigation. Police obtained Zahid's phone records from 2012 and noticed something out of the ordinary. In the three weeks leading up to the annesy shootings, numerous phone calls had been made to and received
老实说，如果法国当局告诉我太阳从东方升起，在西方落下，我会认为他们在撒谎。除非他们有针对他的确凿证据，否则扎伊德在法律上没有义务服从法国的传唤，因此在他的律师建议下，他完全无视了它。这只会增加对他的怀疑。如果扎伊德没有什么可隐瞒的，人们认为他会尽一切努力协助调查。警方获得了扎伊德2012年的电话记录，并注意到了一些不寻常的事情。在安纳西枪击事件发生前的三周内，曾多次拨打和接听
from five different numbers in Romania. The calls had stopped abruptly after the murders. The numbers couldn't be immediately traced, leading investigators to wonder what reason Zaid had to be calling the Balkan country. Zayyid flat out denied making the calls and had no explanation for them. This, coupled with his initial denial that there was any conflict between himself and Assad, along with his refusal to cooperate with the French. investigation brought things to a crescendo. On Monday, June 24, 2013, nine months after the
来自罗马尼亚的五个不同号码的电话。谋杀案发生后，这些电话突然停止了。这些号码无法立即追踪，导致调查人员想知道扎伊德有什么理由给这个巴尔干国家打电话。扎伊德断然否认拨打了这些电话，也没有对此做出任何解释。这一点，加上他最初否认自己和萨德之间存在任何冲突，以及他拒绝配合法国调查，使事情达到了高潮。2013年6月24日星期一，在枪击事件发生九个月后，
shootings, two British detectives visited Zaheed at his flat and placed him under arrest for conspiracy to commit murder. A team of police searched his flat but found nothing to link him to the crime. Zahid was released on bail the following day, which under UK law didn't require a monetary bond. It simply required Zayy to continue living at his current address and stay away from any other potential witnesses. Zahid maintained that he never called anyone in Romania. French investigators looked back over their records and realised he was right. The unexplained calls had actually been made by Sard himself. But months of investigation failed to uncover a single shred of evidence linking Zayyad al-Hilly to the murders.
两名英国侦探拜访了扎伊德的公寓，并以共谋谋杀罪将他逮捕。一队警察搜查了他的公寓，但没有发现任何将他与犯罪联系起来的证据。扎伊德于次日获准保释，根据英国法律，这不需要货币保证金。它只需要扎伊德继续住在目前的地址，并远离任何其他潜在证人。扎伊德坚持认为他从未给罗马尼亚的任何人打过电话。法国调查人员回顾了他们的记录，意识到他是对的。这些无法解释的电话实际上是萨德本人打的。但数月的调查未能发现任何将扎伊德·阿尔-希利与谋杀案联系起来的证据。
His bail conditions were lifted with a spokesperson for the British police announcing. At this stage, there is insufficient evidence to charge him with any criminal offence and no further police action is being taken at this time. French prosecutor Eric Mayhew clarified, this does not mean that we're finished with Zahid al-Hilly, nor that he is innocent. By the one-year anniversary of the shootings, more than the same, three and a half thousand statements had been taken, with lines of inquiry being followed in 23 different countries. With the investigation back to square one, in early November 2013,
他的保释条件被取消，英国警方发言人宣布：“现阶段，没有足够的证据对他提出任何刑事指控，目前不会采取进一步的警察行动。”法国检察官埃里克·马尤澄清说：“这并不意味着我们已经结束了对扎伊德·阿尔-希利的调查，也不意味着他是无辜的。”到枪击事件一周年时，已经记录了超过三千五百份陈述，并在23个不同的国家进行了调查。随着调查回到原点，2013年11月初，
French authorities finally decided to release the suspect sketch of the motorcyclist the forestry workers had seen near Le Martinère right before the shootings. They'd been working hard behind the scenes to identify the distinct dark-colored helmet the rider had been wearing in the hopes this could lead them to its owner. The unusual style of helmet had been produced by a French company called GPA, and there were only 8,000 of the dark-coloured models in circulation. Detectives attempted to track each and every one of them down. They spoke to retailers and motorcycle clubs, monitored online sales,
法国当局终于决定发布林业工人在枪击事件发生前在勒马塔内附近看到的摩托车手的嫌疑人素描。他们一直在幕后努力识别骑手戴的独特的深色头盔，希望这能引导他们找到主人。这种不寻常风格的头盔是由一家名为GPA的法国公司生产的，流通中的深色型号只有8,000个。侦探们试图追踪每一个头盔。他们与零售商和摩托车俱乐部交谈，监控在线销售，
and searched the homes of people who were known to own such helmets. But nothing led them to the mysterious Le Martan. motorcyclist. The decision to release the suspect's sketch paid off. A local who saw the image thought the motorcyclist bore a strong physical resemblance to 48-year-old Eric Dervoisou, a married father of three who lived just a few miles north of the crime scene. Known as an eccentric outdoorsman, Dervoisu had strong knowledge of the woods surrounding
并搜查了已知拥有此类头盔的人的家。但没有任何线索将他们引向神秘的勒马塔内摩托车手。发布嫌疑人素描的决定得到了回报。一位看到图像的当地人认为，这名摩托车手在体型上与48岁的埃里克·德沃伊苏非常相似，他是一位已婚父亲，有三个孩子，住在案发现场以北几英里处。作为一名古怪的户外运动爱好者，德沃伊苏对案发现场周围的树林非常了解，
the murder scene and was familiar with the local mountain routes. Police looked into Eric Dervoisou and discovered that his was one of 4,000 mobile phones that had pinged off the nearest phone tower on the day of the murders. Not only did that put him in the area at the time of the shootings, a background check revealed that in the weeks leading up to the crime, Dervoisu had applied for a firearm permit. He'd previously received combat training as part of his role as a French military reserve and had recently been fired from his job as a munichy. municipal police officer due to alleged misconduct. It was also reported that he held racist views. On Tuesday, February 18, 2014, a team of police officers aided by members of an elite tactical unit raided Eric Dervoiso's home, as well as a property owned by his in-laws. They discovered a collection of approximately 40 weapons, most of which were related to the
并且熟悉当地的山路。警方调查了埃里克·德沃伊苏，发现他的手机是枪击当天在最近的手机信号塔上发出信号的4,000部手机之一。这不仅使他在枪击发生时出现在该地区，背景调查还显示，在犯罪发生前的几周内，德沃伊苏申请了枪支许可证。他曾作为法国预备役军人接受过战斗训练，并因涉嫌不当行为被解雇了市政警察的工作。还有报道称他持有种族主义观点。2014年2月18日星期二，一队警察在精英战术小组成员的协助下，突袭了埃里克·德沃伊苏的家以及他姻亲拥有的房产。他们发现了大约40件武器，其中大部分与
Second World War, and some which had to have. hadn't been obtained legally. They also uncovered similar ammunition to that used in the Luger pistol. Outside Dervoisu's home, a yellow tarpaulin was draped over a large item. Police lifted it up to reveal an old black and grey motorcycle. Both the bike and Dervoisu's helmet were taken away for further examination, while officers searched his back garden with a metal detector. Eric D'Evoisou was taken into police custody and questioned for four days,
第二次世界大战有关，有些是非法获得的。他们还发现了与鲁格手枪中使用的类似的弹药。在德沃伊苏家外，一块黄色防水布覆盖着一个大件物品。警方掀开它，露出一辆旧的黑色和灰色摩托车。摩托车和德沃伊苏的头盔都被带走进行进一步检查，而警官们用金属探测器搜查了他的后花园。埃里克·德沃伊苏被警方拘留并审问了四天，
but he didn't reveal anything that linked him to the annesies shootings, nor was anything discovered in the search to connect him to the crimes. Witnesses who had seen the motorcycle near Le Martinez on the day of the murders were shown Dervoisu's motorbike and concluded it wasn't the same one. He was released without charge. Six months later, the clothing Sard Al-Hilly had been wearing at the time he was killed was re-examined. In his jacket pocket, investigators made an unexpected discovery. There, they found the missing passports belonging to Sard and Dick Bell.
但他没有透露任何将他与安纳西枪击事件联系起来的信息，搜查中也没有发现任何将他与犯罪联系起来的证据。在枪击当天看到勒马塔内附近摩托车的证人被展示了德沃伊苏的摩托车，并得出结论那不是同一辆。他被无罪释放。六个月后，萨德·阿尔-希利遇害时所穿的衣服被重新检查。在夹克口袋里，调查人员有了意外的发现。在那里，他们找到了属于萨德和伊克巴尔的丢失护照。
Zaid Al-Hilly accused the police of incompetence, telling the BBC, It seems that the jacket has been in the lab for a year and a half and no one bothered to search it. So what other evidence have they missed? It was a sentiment echoed by others. With almost two years passing and no significant developments in the case, some questioned whether the police had blundered the investigation from the get-go. When members of the media had first arrived at the crime scene, the police cordon had been temporarily brought down
扎伊德·阿尔-希利指责警方无能，告诉英国广播公司：“看来这件夹克在实验室里放了一年半，没有人费心去搜查它。那么他们还错过了什么其他证据呢？”这是一个被其他人附和的观点。随着近两年过去，案件没有重大进展，一些人质疑警方是否从一开始就搞砸了调查。当媒体成员第一次到达犯罪现场时，警察警戒线被暂时拆除，
so that camera operators and news reporters could wander throughout the parking area and capture their desired footage. This led to accusations that vital evidence could have been missed or compromised. Furthermore, Brett Martin, the witness who discovered the shootings, wasn't even interviewed when police arrived at Le Martinez, despite being covered in blood. By the time police asked to take Brett's clothing as evidence, several days had passed and he'd already washed it. While Brett wasn't involved in any way, it added weight to criticisms that a thorough job
以便摄像师和新闻记者可以在停车区四处走动并捕捉他们想要的镜头。这导致了指控，称重要的证据可能被遗漏或破坏。此外，发现枪击事件的证人布雷特·马丁在警察到达勒马塔内时甚至没有接受采访，尽管他身上沾满了血。当警察要求将布雷特的衣服作为证据时，几天已经过去了，他已经洗过了。虽然布雷特没有以任何方式参与其中，但这增加了人们对从一开始就没有进行彻底工作的批评。
hadn't been done from the start. GQ journalist Sean Flynn remarked, You would think that quadruple homicides, particularly those involving middle-class professionals on vacation, would get sorted out fairly quickly. That scores of detectives hadn't managed to do so suggested either epic incompetence or criminal brilliance. The British investigation team started to grow weary of the French investigation, which had seemingly gone nowhere. The more time that passed, the more convinced they became that Sard and his family had nothing to do with it. By focusing unnecessarily on Zaid Al-Hilly, alternative lines of inquiry had gone cold. For the British investigators, all of the theories involving inheritance disputes,
《GQ》记者肖恩·弗林评论说：“你会认为四重谋杀案，特别是涉及度假的中产阶级专业人士的谋杀案，会很快得到解决。几十名侦探没能做到这一点，要么说明了极度的无能，要么说明了犯罪的才华。”英国调查小组开始对似乎毫无进展的法国调查感到厌倦。时间过得越久，他们就越确信萨德和他的家人与此无关。通过不必要地关注扎伊德·阿尔-希利，其他的调查方向已经变冷了。对于英国调查人员来说，所有涉及遗产纠纷的理论，
industrial espionage, state-sponsored assassinations and spies, were just distractions. from the truth, that the crime had its origins in France. Earlier in 2014, French detectives revisited the possibility that Silvan Molière was the intended target. They compiled a list of anyone acquainted with Silvan or his partner Claire and set up routine interviews with each individual. Among them was 50-year-old Patrice Menagaudo, an Eugene firefighter who had previously served as a paratrooper for the French Foreign Legion. He was questioned for under an hour, but it was clear he had nothing to add. Police sent him on his way with no further thought. Two months later, Patrice took his own life. He left behind a letter that included a surprising
工业间谍活动、国家支持的暗杀和间谍行为，都只是为了掩盖真相的干扰项，这起犯罪的根源其实在法国。2014年初，法国侦探重新审视了西尔万·莫利耶（Silvan Molière）可能是预定目标的可能性。他们列出了一份所有与西尔万或其伴侣克莱尔（Claire）相识的人的名单，并安排了例行面谈。其中一人是50岁的帕特里斯·梅纳戈多（Patrice Menagaudo），他是一名尤金（Eugene）的消防员，曾担任法国外籍军团的伞兵。他接受了不到一小时的询问，但很明显他没有什么可补充的。警方让他离开了，没有多想。两个月后，帕特里斯自杀了。他留下了一封信，其中包含了一个令人惊讶的
explanation for his abrupt suicide. He couldn't handle being considered a suspect for the annesies shootings. Investigators were stunned. They'd never considered Patrice to be a person of interest, nor was he ever held in custody. But now they were left wondering whether Patrice Menagado had killed himself because he was in fact involved with the crime and was consumed by guilt. It seemed so illogical that a hardened soldier who had firsthand experience in foreign conflicts would be driven to the brink by something as minor as a cursory police interview, unless he had something to hide. An examination of Patrice's life revealed he suffered psychological problems from his 20 years in the
关于他突然自杀的解释。他无法承受被视为安纳西枪击案嫌疑人的压力。调查人员感到震惊。他们从未将帕特里斯视为相关人员，他也从未被拘留过。但现在他们不禁怀疑，帕特里斯·梅纳戈多是否因为确实参与了这起犯罪并被内疚感吞噬而自杀。对于一个在外国冲突中有过亲身经历的硬汉士兵来说，仅仅因为一次草率的警方询问就被逼到绝境，这似乎太不合逻辑了，除非他有什么隐情。对帕特里斯生活的调查显示，他在
Foreign Legion. He was also proficient with firearms and had local knowledge of the Chevoline area. All of these factors fit the profile for the annesy shooter, but they didn't explain why Patrice waited two months after being interviewed by police to end his life. and if he was responsible, why had it taken almost two years since the crime for the guilt to finally become unbearable? Patrice Managado quickly rose to the top of the suspect list, but an in-depth inquiry failed to find any evidence to link him to the crime. September 2014 came and went, marking a bitter two-year anniversary of the unsolved crime. In a bid to identify the mysterious motorcyclist seen near the crime scene, police continued to cross-check mobile phone records with motorcycle license data.
外籍军团服役的20年里患上了心理问题。他还精通枪支，并对谢沃林（Chevoline）地区很了解。所有这些因素都符合安纳西枪手的特征，但它们无法解释为什么帕特里斯在接受警方询问后等了两个月才结束自己的生命。如果他是肇事者，为什么在犯罪发生近两年后，内疚感才变得难以忍受？帕特里斯·梅纳戈多很快成为了嫌疑人名单上的首位，但深入调查未能找到任何将他与犯罪联系起来的证据。2014年9月过去了，这起未破案件迎来了痛苦的两周年纪念。为了查明在犯罪现场附近看到的神秘摩托车手，警方继续将手机记录与摩托车牌照数据进行交叉比对。
In February 2015, their hard work finally paid off. The rider was identified as a 57-year-old man from the city of Leon, located roughly 150 kilometres west of Chevoline. He explained that he'd been in the Annesie region on the day of the shootings by accident. He was an enthusiastic paraglider and the particularly nice weather that day had inspired him to ride the hills above Lake Anasi
2015年2月，他们的努力终于有了回报。这名骑手被确认为一名来自里昂市的57岁男子，该市位于谢沃林以西约150公里处。他解释说，他那天出现在安纳西地区纯属偶然。他是一位热衷于滑翔伞运动的人，那天特别好的天气激发了他骑车前往安纳西湖上方山丘的兴趣，
to scope the area for potential paragliding spots. He recalled having a brief encounter with the two forestry workers but said he left the area after they warned him about the restricted road. He hadn't noticed anything suspicious and hadn't been following the story of the murders in the media, so it never even occurred to him to come forward to clear himself as a witness. Police had no reason to doubt this man's story. He was a reputable businessman with a wife and children and no criminal record.
去考察该地区是否有潜在的滑翔伞地点。他回忆说曾与两名林业工人有过短暂接触，但表示在他们警告他关于限制道路后就离开了该区域。他没有注意到任何可疑情况，也没有关注媒体上关于谋杀案的报道，所以他从未想过要站出来澄清自己作为证人的身份。警方没有理由怀疑这个人的故事。他是一位有声望的商人，有妻子和孩子，没有犯罪记录。
Nothing about him fit the profile of the killer, nor was there any evidence to link him to the crime. He was released without charge, with his name suppressed from the media. Identifying the motorcyclist after all this time was a woman. significant development, but all it did was rule out the possibility that the motorcyclist was involved. If anything, it was a case of one step forward, two steps back. As the years continued to pass with no breakthroughs, a new French prosecutor and lead British detective were eventually assigned to the case. They revisited the evidence from scratch in the hopes that fresh eyes might uncover new leads. The British team officially
他身上没有任何特征符合杀手的形象，也没有任何证据将他与犯罪联系起来。他被无罪释放，媒体也未披露他的名字。在这么久之后确认了摩托车手的身份是一个重大进展，但这仅仅排除了摩托车手参与其中的可能性。如果说有什么的话，那就是进了一步，退了两步。随着岁月流逝，案件仍无突破，一位新的法国检察官和首席英国侦探最终被指派负责此案。他们从头开始重新审视证据，希望新的视角能发现新的线索。英国团队正式
cleared Zaheed Al-Hilly from their list of suspects. Zaheed told the Channel 4 documentary Murder in the Alps that the whole falling out with his brother was, quote, stupid and silly, and it shouldn't really have happened, but you can't turn the clock back. Zahid believes the investigation was thwarted from the beginning, and that French investigators were blindsided by racism. They didn't want the crime to have originated in their country,
将扎希德·阿尔-希利（Zaheed Al-Hilly）从他们的嫌疑人名单中剔除。扎希德在第四频道纪录片《阿尔卑斯山的谋杀案》中表示，与他兄弟之间的一切不和都是“愚蠢和幼稚的”，本不该发生，但时光无法倒流。扎希德认为调查从一开始就受到了阻挠，法国调查人员被种族主义蒙蔽了双眼。他们不希望这起犯罪起源于他们的国家，
so they saw the Middle Eastern Finlayers. family as the perfect cover-up. Zahid told GQ Magazine. To be honest with you, I don't think there was an investigation. I think this was a declaration of war against us. I think they hoped these Arabs would be terrorists or drug dealers. I think we were manor from heaven for them. The former lead investigator for the British team, Mark Preston,
所以他们将中东裔的阿尔-希利一家视为完美的替罪羊。扎希德告诉《GQ》杂志：“老实说，我不认为这是一次调查。我认为这是对我们宣战。我想他们希望这些阿拉伯人是恐怖分子或毒贩。我想我们对他们来说是天降横财。”英国团队的前首席调查员马克·普雷斯顿（Mark Preston），
appeared on the same Channel 4 documentary to reveal some new information for the first time. He said that just before the shootings, Silvan Moliere's bicycle chain had come loose. Ballistic evidence indicated that Sylvan had been shot when he was slightly bent over. Preston hypothesized that the killer could have been hiding in some nearby trees and pulled the trigger when Silvan stopped to check his bike chain. He stated, You don't need to be a seasoned investigator to realize that the person who is shot first, last, and most, is not going to be the witness, it is going to be the intended target. To me, it was very clear the killer wanted Molière dead.
出现在同一部第四频道纪录片中，首次透露了一些新信息。他说，在枪击事件发生前不久，西尔万·莫利耶的自行车链条松了。弹道证据表明，西尔万在稍微弯腰时被击中。普雷斯顿推测，杀手可能一直躲在附近的树丛中，当西尔万停下来检查自行车链条时扣动了扳机。他指出：“你不需要成为一名经验丰富的调查员就能意识到，第一个、最后一个且被射击次数最多的人，不会是证人，而会是预定目标。对我来说，很明显杀手想要莫利耶死。”
The French investigation team disputed this, as it was scientifically impossible to determine the order in which the victims were shot. By 2021, three French investigators continued to work on the case full-time. They trawled through the files, starting to be the case. from scratch to see if anything had been missed. A full reconstruction of the crime scene was done, complete with witnesses. In February, the new lead prosecutor, Lin Bonnet, told Swiss reporters, I think we're nearly there, will succeed thanks to scientific evidence. This is not a cold case at all.
法国调查组对此表示异议，因为科学上无法确定受害者被射击的顺序。到2021年，三名法国调查员继续全职处理此案。他们翻阅了档案，从头开始梳理案件，看看是否有遗漏之处。在证人的配合下，对犯罪现场进行了全面重建。2月，新任首席检察官林·邦内（Lin Bonnet）告诉瑞士记者：“我认为我们快要成功了，我们将借助科学证据取得成功。这根本不是冷案。”
Four months later, the unnamed motorcyclist who had previously been cleared from the investigation was placed under arrest. It's unclear if this was based on the revelation of any new evidence. The man was questioned in custody, but released shortly after, with his lawyer stating, I hope that those guilty will be found, and I hope my client will never be considered a suspect again. This man's position is still the same. He did not cross paths with this poor family.
四个月后，之前已被排除在调查之外的那名未具名摩托车手被捕。目前尚不清楚这是否基于任何新证据的披露。该男子在拘留期间接受了询问，但不久后被释放，他的律师表示：“我希望罪犯能被找到，也希望我的客户永远不会再被视为嫌疑人。我当事人的立场依然如故。他没有与这个可怜的家庭有过交集。”
According to some reports, he remains. a suspect. With nothing to link either the Al-Hillis or Silvan-Mollier to the motive for the crime, the prevailing theory for French investigators is that the annesy shootings were most likely a random attack, committed by a lone gunman with no ties to the victims. The unsolved case has piqued the interest of many online sleuths. They continue to discuss possible theories, including that the victims could have been targeted by one of several serial killers who were active around France and Switzerland. Investigators have considered this theory too, but ultimately ruled it out.
据一些报道称，他仍然是一名嫌疑人。由于没有任何证据将阿尔-希利一家或西尔万·莫利耶与犯罪动机联系起来，法国调查人员的主流理论是，安纳西枪击案很可能是一起随机袭击，由一名与受害者毫无关联的独狼枪手所为。这起未破案件引起了许多网络侦探的兴趣。他们继续讨论各种可能的理论，包括受害者可能是法国和瑞士周边活跃的几名连环杀手之一的目标。调查人员也考虑过这一理论，但最终排除了它。
Zainab and Zina Al-Hilly are now teenagers and have since been given new identities. In June 2022, British investigators interviewed Zainab one more time to see if she could offer any further insight almost a decade after the fact. According to Liu Parisian newspaper, Zainab's recollection was now clearer. After arriving at Le Matanet, Zainab and Sard got out of the car. She remembered seeing Silvan Moliere on his bicycle. As the rest of her family were about to get out, gunshot suddenly rang out. Zanab's parents ordered her back into the vehicle, but as she tried to get back in, she was grabbed from behind.
扎伊纳布（Zainab）和齐娜（Zina）·阿尔-希利现在已是青少年，并已获得新的身份。2022年6月，英国调查人员再次采访了扎伊纳布，看看在事发近十年后她是否能提供进一步的见解。据《巴黎人报》报道，扎伊纳布的回忆现在更清晰了。到达勒马塔内（Le Matanet）后，扎伊纳布和萨德（Saad）下了车。她记得看到西尔万·莫利耶骑着自行车。当她家人的其余成员正要下车时，枪声突然响起。扎伊纳布的父母命令她回到车里，但当她试图回去时，她从后面被抓住了。
She first thought the person who grabbed her was her father, until she caught a glimpse of their bare hands and realized they were white. Zayneb struggled, but was unable to free herself from their grip. All she could remember before losing consciousness was that the killer was wearing long trousers and a leather jacket. With the ongoing conjecture, many who have worked on the case describe it as one of the most difficult they've ever been involved with. as prosecutor Eric Mayu remarked to journalist Tom Parry
她起初以为抓住她的人是她父亲，直到她瞥见对方裸露的手，意识到那是白人的手。扎伊纳布挣扎着，但无法从对方的控制中挣脱。在失去知觉前，她唯一记得的是杀手穿着长裤和皮夹克。随着不断的猜测，许多参与过此案的人将其描述为他们所处理过的最困难的案件之一。正如检察官埃里克·马约（Eric Maillaud）对记者汤姆·帕里（Tom Parry）所言：
We have tried everything possible, but perhaps we're in the presence of the perfect crime. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“我们已经尝试了一切可能的方法，但也许我们面对的是一起完美犯罪。”本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。